uh thank you ladies and gentlemen uh
good evening members officers Democratic
Services we have tonight and members of
the public I'm not sure if we have any
press here tonight but welcome to them
if there are and welcome to this
planning committee meeting of the I've
got the 14th of February on the top of
my notes here but I think that was
yesterday so I haven't got any roses for
anyone tonight uh a little bit of
housekeeping as always if the fire alarm
is activated please vacate the offices
by the stairs opposite the lifts that
you may well have used to come into the
chamber
I will advise you
when it will be safe to come back in
um but ask you to go over to Holy Square
green uh once it's safe to come back in
say you will be advised to do so there's
also an exit door to my right does
anybody
intend filming this meeting tonight
no okay thank you I will remind members
and the members of the public that we
are being live streamed on the councils
YouTube channel and if obviously you
can't see it tonight but it will be
there I believe late tonight or as from
tomorrow
restrictions of mobile phones I would
ask everybody present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls in the chamber whilst this
meeting is in progress
members who would wish to speak under
Council procedure 20.1
I have counselor Pugh which is to speak
on item r02
and counselor fellows on item mode 2
speaking and these award councilors
um so uh
item 05 councilor cup and again
councilor fellows
foreign applications have been reserved
for public speaking the members please
make a note that they are important
items on the agenda
item 4A which is 3A Roseberry Avenue
Ramsgate item 4B unit one and two
belgrave Road Margate item 4C 45 Stanley
Road Pro stairs item 4D land adjacent to
12 to 14 Fort Road Margate and item 4E
which is the 05 Gore Farm in gorin farm
in this road birchington
agenda item one which is apologies for
absence we have apologies for counselor
shrub I have Council of Dave Saunders
standing in Kansas shrub also for
councilor Paul Moore I have councilor
Maeve Saunders standard in for Council
for more
gender items
sorry
thank you Council Everett
are there any decorations of Interest
please show
no thank you
now gender item three minutes of the
planning meeting which was held on the
18th of January the members agree that
these minutes of the planning committee
meeting held on the 18th of January 2022
three
be uh I I will apologize I go by my
script down here so um
I correct it doesn't go along but
please uh it's all here that they
approved and correct
that part wasn't a record of that
meeting could I have a proposal please
councilor Auburn seconder councilor
Coleman cook do members agree
thank you
I should check the dates as we go along
agenda item four if there are any site
visits for the committee they would take
place on Friday the 3rd of March 2023
and normally as I've mentioned before
around about 9 30 in the morning
uh point of information
Mr Livingston
thank you chair
um point of information for members on
agenda item for E for the development at
Gore and farm birchington the published
recommendation to defer and delegate to
officers for approval subject to the
satisfactory completion of a 106
agreement to secure the required Highway
contribution for maintenance of the
proposed traffic light system and
resolution of the technical approval
process was a requirement of KCC
highways effectively which required the
process of securing agreement under
Section 278 of the Highway Act and the
contribution that's paid through that
process to occur prior to planning
permission being issued so that that was
what KCC stated to us however from
further discussions with KCC
they've stated that the required
separate process of the 278 agreement
would sufficiently cover the
requirements regarding the technical
design of the new access and traffic
lights and therefore a legal agreement
related to the planning permission is is
now considered unnecessary now on this
basis there's no need to defer the
application to officers so it's for
members to determine this evening
and therefore officers are recommending
that the application be approved subject
to the conditions outlined in the report
with one additional planning condition
and that would be that no development
should take place until the Full
Construction and operation details of
the proposed traffic light system and
areas of adoption have been submitted to
and approved in writing by the local
planning Authority in consultations with
the highway Authority and the
development should be carried out in
accordance with those approved details
and the ground of that condition would
be in the interests of Highway Safety
thank you chair thank you very much Ian
agenda item for a 3A Roseberry Avenue
Ramsgate speaking in favor of this
application do we have Mr Robert
brittner with us tonight
no
I take it you are Miss McFarland
you have three minutes to give your
report thank you
could you put your mic on push the
button
it's there thank you very much sorry
um it's all very new sorry
um chairman members thank you
unfortunately my agent can't be here
tonight here's a family emergency
however he has provided me with what he
had intended to say this application
seems to have aroused an organized
opposition much for which shows a lack
of knowledge of the actual proposal
opposition centers around three issues
drainage parking and holiday makers
taking drainage first we want to make
the site as eco-friendly as possible
recycling gray water for garden
irrigation and installing an electrical
incinerator toilet to deal with waste if
those Ambitions are not achievable
Southern Waters confirmed that there is
no objection to us connecting to the
Sewer in rosebery Avenue which connects
to a combined sewer at the junction with
Harrison Road
as to traffic and parking the cabin has
one double bedroom which would
accommodate one couple at most who would
need only one car and there is space for
that on site the manufacturer of the
cabin optimistically refers to a
sleeping platform but that is wholly
within the cramped roof slopes with a
height of less than 1.5 meters it's
really just a storage space
the risk of more than two persons being
present is therefore negligible
Roseberry Avenue has a parking problem
with too many car owners and almost a
complete lack of off-road parking that
is evident but this will not make things
worse it has an on-site parking space
that won't affect the street
thirdly this is not a holiday Lodge it's
the wrong building in the wrong place
and no matter how nicely we manage to do
the garden it's never going to be an
attractive holiday destination our aim
is to provide an artist some writer's
Retreat where those of an artistic or
literary bent can come to rest and think
and recharge their batteries perhaps get
some work done in solitude and quietude
this will be a small part of the
Renaissance of Ramsgate that we've been
trying to help support with our shop
tails on moon Lane on Addington Street
in Ramsgate
and lastly chairman if it's not our
proposition then what an appeal for a
dwelling on the site was turned down
some years ago but that was due to the
details of the scheme not the principle
if this project fails some other will
come forward a dwelling perhaps or a
resurrection of the storage yards the
Builder's yard that it's got permission
for at the moment we hope that you will
feel able to support this original
proposal instead thank you
uh thank you very much and uh speaking
against this application is that Mr Andy
doody
yes you have again three minutes
[Music]
thank you
I'm falling over right
yeah
I'm here this evening to voice strong
opposition on behalf of the many
residents in rosebery Avenue Ramsgate
to the proposed planning application
that seeks to construct and have a
glamping pod shed on the site
renting it out as a holiday let as it
said on the original planning
as well as the disruption disruption
that's already been caused by the
utility services that are supplied to
the site already with roads and
Pavements being closed without any
warning
leaving damage to the pavement that is
still there mud all over the place they
also left a wide and deep trench that
was left wide open and had to be filled
in by David from number five for Public
Safety
the access track
to this site runs is narrow and it runs
between numbers three and five who both
have a right of way
on that track to access their their
Garden Gates
um the family homes both sides of the
track have several windows at ground
level so the privacy of the residents
will be a great concern
to them especially number three has two
babies number five regularly has
grandchildren there
and to be able to turn onto this track
which Rosemary Avenue is a very narrow
road as you say parking is a real
problem
I have a registered enforced disabled by
Bank opposite it I've had my car hit
three times
it's you have to turn at a right angle
there's no view to see coming in and out
which is why we've had accidents at the
bottom of the road
we've also had problems with Emergency
Services both for myself with ambulance
and far engine who couldn't get up the
road and other residents that have had a
fire
fire engine just couldn't get up there
um
sorry bear with me
so restrictions on the mid emergency
vehicle access would have a significant
impact on the response times for all of
the residents in that road and make it
difficult more difficult for emergency
services
yes it was a builder's yard that was 75
years ago we've got residents that have
lived down there 40 years plus it hasn't
been used as a builder's yard and it was
a storage yard
um and I understand for artists
poets people that want to be a Solitude
I can understand that I go fishing
that's my my respite
but it's alongside Ramsgate the one of
the football pitches that's used every
Saturday and Sunday
it's overlooked it's a cramped area
um
what else can I say the wooden shed
we've been looking into these poles
because I've stayed in one when I've
been fishing and I left it too late but
there's some examples printed out there
they have a habit of Catching Fire
there's several right does that mean
she's finished if you have a few more
lines just a few mainly the safety on
these because even if they have a
barbecue or fireworks which and I know
the lady said one car two people but
what if their family wants to visit or
the grandchildren want to come and stay
there can be more than one car
the appearance is a worry
and also the drainage
already this week rescue jet have been
down there
because there's more problems with the
sewers again there's been constant road
closures on his and Road they ask you to
wind up Mr if you would please do me
thank you thank you very much indeed
I'll ask the plan of obviously to
outline the report which I believe is
Emma I think Emma
determine this is the site outlined in
red here so you can see Roseberry Avenue
and the bottomless slide on the right
hand side of the slide is hereson Road
and so you can see there's a an access
that runs between number three and five
Rosemary Avenue and this is the area of
land to
um the rear of the site so it's a
separate plot and related to the other
properties around it
so this is just some aerial views of the
site so the the plot is here so that
this is the application site and you can
see the access that runs
um along here between numbers three and
five Rosemary Avenue and again on this
one here you can see again the plot so
it's and to the rear of numbers three
and um one Roseberry Avenue
and then this is just a image taken from
some of our older map maps so this is
from 2018
um showing a building privacy on the
site and we have
um evidence of this from the mapping
going back as as early as 2012.
um the former use of the site is as an
open storage yard
this is the site here so you can see
this is the access run into the
application site so you can see it has
an existing drop curb so it is an
established access to the rear of the
site and you can see number three and
five in this photo and you can see the
side windows that have just been
referred to within their site elevations
that face onto that access
and then this is the accessing closer
detail again you can see the the windows
in closer detail so the application site
includes this access and then the area
to the right hand side here and then
this photo's been taken very recently
but I now have some photos just from um
last year so this was the access last
year when some work was taking place and
this is the rear of the site just so you
can see the um this area so the the area
referred to is
this part here you can see and it also
extends behind this um blue uh
outbuilding you can see on the right
hand side here
and again another view so the area
extends Beyond this plot here on the
right and behind this plot here
so this is just some views taken from
raspberry Avenue just so you can see the
the situation because parking has been
mentioned so just a few photos showing
the situation the roads so this
obviously taken during the day but it
does show there is some
um availability within the site within
the road for on-shoot parking during the
day and you can see
um this is here's some Road here and the
application site is just on the left
hand side here so these are the
properties of back on to the application
site
and again just another view in here soon
so this is the proposal this is the
proposed block plan so it's showing
um the proposed holiday let cabin in
this location here
so it's a meter from each of the
boundaries of of uh of the with the
neighboring properties you can see a two
meter high fence a brick wall in this
location
1.8 meter brick wall and uh fencing runs
around the rest of the site so there's
High Bounty treatment around it
again you see the access that runs up to
the site here and this area here is
allocated as a parking a parking area
associated with the cabin
so you can see the distance to
neighboring properties there's no
concerns regarding lighter Outlook given
the distance because it's just single
story in terms of the measurements it's
2.2 meters to ease level so
um 0.4 above the lowest boundary
treatment on the site and it goes up to
3.9 meters to Ridge level
this is just a floor plan showing the
the um the unit so it's it basically has
like a a communal space with a bedroom
and a bathroom at ground floor level and
then there would be
um a small uh
sort of sleeping area at first floor but
not really first of all it's kind of
like a
um actually I'll show you in the
elevation sorry it's difficult to
explain from that so here you go this is
the elevation so at this level here
within the roof there is like a um a
floor that would allow potentially some
sleeping Bots he doesn't have full head
height so it's not an actual proper
first floor
um this is the elevation and facing
um the high boundary treatment so as I
said it was 2.2 meters to ease level so
fencing would be only slightly lower
than that so it's considered that there
wouldn't be any direct overlooking to
neighboring properties from these
windows at ground floor level and
because the the fence and the walls
would screen the majority of this window
um there's a small vdux in the roof at
this level and this is the front
elevation of the um cabin so these are
the entrance doors and the windows that
will face onto the parking area and
there's a slight overhang at roof level
here
and then this is a real renovation with
a high level window so I suppose that
this would be obscure glaze because of
it first or level there there's there is
the potential for some overlooking from
this window although it's quite small so
the agent has agreed to the Obscure
glazing of this window
and this is the other elevation
um facing again just High boundary
treatment around the site
so um the main consideration is in fact
it's previously developed land it's
previously been used as open storage use
so what we're looking at now is a
proposed um C3 use in the form of a
holiday let so because of the size of
the unit it doesn't meet minimum space
standards so there would be conditions
that would be would restrict the use of
this to a holiday let only so it could
never become a permanent form of
accommodation
because it is proposed as a holiday let
we need to consider policy e08 for
tourism benefits so the tourism policy
supports tourism where it's sustainably
located and of a form and scale
appropriate to his surroundings
so given the fact it's it's single story
and not causing any significant harm in
terms of its proximity to neighboring
properties and given the fact it's quite
a sustainable site so within here some
Road there's
um bus routes and so it's it's quite
soon be located and there is space for
parking it's considered that it is
um it would be supported by this policy
so whilst some neighbors raised concerns
to do with the noise and disturbance to
the side windows
consideration needs to be given to the
fact that it is an established access
and as you saw from the photo it does
have a drop curb already and it has
previously been used as open storage use
and so we need to look at where you know
what the site could be used for and how
that compares to this proposed use and
whether there's actually any increased
harm as a result of this proposed use so
this is a single bedroom within the
cabin so potentially up to two people
would would be using this site
it's not considered that that would be
significantly increased noise and
disturbance on these neighboring
occupiers when compared to the open
storage use that could result in more
Vehicles using the site than that
there's no restrictions on on the use of
the site so it's not considered that
there that there would be a significant
increase in noise and disturbance to to
these neighboring occupiers
in terms of the highway side of things
again they have an offshoot parking
space being proposed with the cabin
given the fact there's only one bedroom
this would be adequate to meet the the
hiring requirements for the site
um I think whilst initially High
highways did raise concerns with the
some lack of visibility from this access
again it is an established access so
we're unable to really make any changes
to that again vehicles in relation to
the storage use could use that access so
there's there's
um no objection to the actual design of
the access
um
so it is is recommended for um approval
a unilateral undertaking has been
submitted to secure the spa contribution
given the fact that it is a C3 use and
this has been submitted
um so subject to the conditions that
look to restrict it to a holiday let use
it's considered to be an acceptable form
of previous developed land and it's
recommended for approval thank you thank
you very much Emma I moved the offers as
recommendation which you heard is for
approval with the vice chair please
second
Council bayford
thank you chair
um personally I can't see any problem
with this application my question is
just that
um the established access route
um does is that wide enough for
emergency vehicles and refuse collection
vehicles
can you answer them no it wouldn't be
wide enough for a natural
um like refuse truck to get down there
so they would have to like for Refuge
they would have to bring waste to the
front of the site and leave it on the
pavement and like neighboring properties
would do and in terms of
um like fire safety I think it I think
it was native we're in the report that
it is too far away for
um potentially a fire engine to reach
but then in these sort of occasions we
do encourage them to use a sprinkler
system and build a control usually quite
happy with that that um process
thank you Council Keane
very strange place for a retreat to me
but you know that's by the buy but I do
have a couple of concerns about it the
first one is the Kent fire and rescue
weren't consulted on this application
I've noted in the report it says about
the distance being enough for the um uh
I don't know pumping Appliance has to be
within a certain distance and it's
within that distance but my question
then is what about ladders if ladders
are required how do they get ladders up
there
um but so personally I would have liked
to have seen comment from Kent fire and
rescue on this the other thing is
um I know it's got the parking space but
is that space big enough for a car to
turn especially given the size of some
Modern cars these days so there are a
couple of questions I would like thank
you
am I Jewish
King
thank you um I wanted to comment on the
parking in Roseberry Avenue itself the
pictures that we saw with lots of lovely
parking space in my job my day job
um I often have to visit this area after
six o'clock at night and if I can get a
parking space anywhere nearer than
dumpton Park railway station I'm
actually whooping with joy it is
absolutely nothing like that so I just
think we need to bear in mind that the
pictures we've seen are are not actually
representative of what it's like when
it's not daytime and that also then
leads me to one of my my concerns is
that I know this is an existing access
point but how easy is it to act uh
getting and out of it when there's cars
parked opposite because that's not a
terribly wide Road either
um
it does look as though there's probably
room for a parking space in that area
based on
on that drawing there
but that's quite a long distance if
you've got a vehicle that can't turn
around in that space that's a long
distance reversing or out so those are
just my my thoughts and any comments on
that um would be appreciated
thank you Emma can you come back
[Music]
um so in terms of the parking just
looking at the measurements for that
space it's
um eight meters by 7.3
um so I mean it it would be tight
um but you would be able to get a
vehicle in and you would have to do more
than a three-point turn I would say
probably to get out but there would be
space to to potentially turn for a
smaller vehicle within that space
um
so and and again the fact it is an
established access again
um Vehicles linked to the open storage
use could go up there and use that space
now so again it's it's very difficult
for us to object to something that is
already established so I'll just go back
and just show the photo again because I
know you'll mentioning about
um
sort of visibility and potential for
cars or parking side and obviously you
can see there's a full dropped curb
along
um the width of that axis yes cars could
park close to it but again it's just
very difficult for us to object or
something when it is an existing
situation there's they have for us to
refuse something on highway safety
grounds there has to be a severe impact
on highway safety and this wouldn't be
something to Warrant that refusal
uh thank you did you pick up Council
uh no sir I'm sorry we're not I can't do
that so
um I've got
counselor
a council King this has been an answer
to the fire and rescue question
carry on
can you answer
Ed
um I'll come in on that chair thank you
um so yeah Ken Farm Rescue weren't
consulted so they're not a statutory
consultant for this type of development
and as Emma outlined this is where
building control legislation and
planning permission sort of cross over
and in terms of building a structure
such as this the requirement would be to
satisfy building rigs which would deal
with fire safety and as identified it is
fully expected that they'd have to have
a sprinkler system to be put in to that
that structure to be safe for for
Harrisburg accommodation
valuation
thank you Council Everett
thank you chair I mean I have to say
that my sympathy is largely with the
residents
um I think this is a strange application
I think the idea that somebody would
want to build a um holiday accommodation
in that particular position is um
unusual
um no disrespect to the to the business
owner and and trying to make the best of
the site and clearly the fact that they
intended to be used for writers and
artists and artistic people is not
something that which we can rely on in
planning terms so we have to consider
that it might be used by holiday makers
in the future the current owners might
not own it in future future owners might
have different ideas the real difficulty
we have is that um what it could be used
for as is
um is probably worse than what's
proposed here and in particular the
vehicle access is there and can be used
now
and therefore despite the fact that we
recognize the problems with uh with the
road and parking and the road and access
in and out of the site there ain't
nothing we can do about that
um in the planning system
um so I'm sort of struggling really to
find any grounds on which we could
reject it
um and and reliably expect that decision
to be upheld so one I'll ask about is
that the existing uses well it's been
used for building storage if you think
it's been a builder's yard at some part
some point in the historic past
presumably those uses of things which
take place during the working day
um this use one would assume will take
place overnight and could result in
noise from that kind of use is that
something that the committee could take
into account or would or would that be
unreasonable of itself
um yes it is a case that a storage use
is more likely to be during the day but
um as far as we're aware there's no
restrictions on the use of this site at
all so whilst that is more likely to be
the case it would be used during the day
it could be used at weekends it could be
you Sundays and there's no restriction
of what time it would stop being used
um because we're not aware of any
restrictions on it so yes with a
residential use you could have people
walking along the lane late at night
that you might not get from an open
storage use but again we are talking
only one unit of accommodation here with
one bedroom so it's not likely to be a
significant impact from noise and
disturbance from one or two people that
would be using this this unit I think if
it was if more than that then maybe we
could be considering it but with only
one or two people it's not likely to
cause significant harm to again warrant
refusal
thank you uh Council Robin
yes thank you chair um I think I do
concur with some of my colleagues in
relation to
um the location for this it does seem
slightly weird but however looking at
the building itself
where it's situated uh I can't see
there's no problem with the building
height wise intrusiveness or anything of
that nature uh if you're building a
house there you wouldn't be looking at
noise would you you wouldn't be looking
at some are going to cause noise in a
house because you can deal with that in
in other ways for environmental health
uh if there are noise issues
um so I I dismiss that as far as
planning uh concerns are the access of
course is is narrow but as a builder's
yard they wouldn't be walking up there
with a wheelbarrow would they be going
up there with a van they would have
turned around and come back there's been
a building on the site already as we've
seen so I can't see a problem why we
would refuse it here thank you thank you
very much Council Auburn
I'm sorry Madam I'm sorry I cannot allow
you to speak I'm sorry
Madam I am sorry I'm not allowed to let
you speak I'm sorry
uh are there any other members wish to
speak
okay you've heard the recommendation is
for approval could members show if they
approve the subcation
those against
abstentions
that is carried and approved thank you
members
I will just give a moment while members
of public
uh thank you for that members
moving on to agenda item 4B which is
unit one and two belgrove Road Margate
speaking in favor of this occupation is
Miss Liz Gibney if she's there
evening I hope I've pronounced that
right so that's fine thank you I've had
worse thank you
okay
um good evening everybody I'm Liz Gibney
I'm a partner at Lee Evans partnership
and I'm speaking this evening on behalf
of the applicant I am I'll be brief but
speak in support of approval for this
scheme and ask that you vote in favor of
the proposal this evening the scheme
before you represents a significant
investment in the continued regeneration
of this part of Margate the aim is to
revitalize a Brownfield site within the
urban confines of central Margate
through the Redevelopment of a highly
sustainable location a range of public
transport options in an interesting way
that reflects the unique and exciting
character of Margate and its much
celebrated Seaside beachfront location
the scheme will Breathe new life into
the existing building for further
re-energizing this part of the Town
significantly looking for investment
just beyond the seafront
proposal will provide 10 high quality
new homes offering
Improvement to the local housing mix and
three commercial premises at ground
floor level there will be no loss of
commercial uses although they will be
different
in respect of Heritage we consider the
scheme provides an appropriate
contextual response to the setting of
the site a Heritage statement prepared
by a specialist conservation architect
directly informs The Proposal comments
were received from the conservation
officer after the applicant had informed
the intention to refuse the scheme and
we haven't been able to discuss this
since
um which we would have liked to have
done in respect of overlooking the
officer records that this concern could
be overcome by the installation
privacy screens this suggestion had not
been previously shared with the
applicant but I can confirm that the
applicant would accept a condition to
provide details of balcony screens to
overcome these concerns this would
resolve proposed refusal reason two
we would also consider conditions to
look at anything to do with materials or
color or appearance refusal reasons
three and four relate to section 106
agreement and Sam's contributions the
applicant has no objection at all to
Preparing the necessary heads of terms
and financial contributions to resolve
these issues this would resolve proposed
refusal reasons three and four overall
the principle of development is
acceptable in this location as agreed by
the officer there are no technical
objections to the proposal including
matters of Highways drainage subject to
planning conditions and contributions
the applicant agrees to all conditions
and contributions suggested to date
in view of the council not demonstrating
a five-year housing land Supply
um The Proposal will directly contribute
to the aims of the action plan in
delivering housing and Accords with the
objectives of the mppf in delivering
development in sustainable locations on
this basis we submit this screen scheme
as of being a real Merit and acceptable
in terms of planning policies when
waiting against other material
considerations encourage you to support
a resolution to Grant planning and be a
positive part of creating new homes in
Margate we think this is a real
regeneration scheme that really aligns
with the vision and the strategy for the
whole town
and looking at regeneration rather than
just preservation so thank you very much
thank you very much speaking against the
application is Miss Geraldine Scott if
she's there I'm here thank you chair you
have three minutes thank you for the
opportunity to speak this evening I'm a
resident at Grosvenor place and I
strongly object to the planning
application for the change of use from
the existing commercial use to a
mixed-use development first of all I
want to state that I have no objection
to the commercial units at the
development there are already existing
commercial units on the site nor do I
have any objection to the proposal to
develop self-contained Flats above new
commercial units housing is needed in
the area and any proposal to increase
Supply is welcome my primary objection
to the scheme is the external appearance
of the development and how it will
impact on the surrounding area which is
a designated Conservation Area
aesthetically the proposed design would
not enhance the attractiveness of the
local area instead it has the potential
to become a local Landmark for all the
wrong reasons and I saw rather than an
asset
the colors for the facade are garish
yellow glazed bricks orange vertical
metal cladding dark green lower
elevation and black doors and windows
the design appears to be a nod to the
Dreamland Heritage of the surrounding
area however it is a residential
building primarily and therefore not in
keeping with the vernacular of the
surrounding area
the rear elevation with its proposed
metal cross braces mesh and Timber fins
would blight The View down Eaton Hill
from Grosvenor place and isn't
complementary to the architecture along
Eaton Road
three additional floors on top of the
existing building would greatly increase
the density on this site if additional
floors were in keeping with the existing
building and the access to the flats
were enclosed rather than external to
the building that might prove a more
attractive proposition however the
design is currently conceived is
disruptive rather than sympathetic the
external access wall ways on walkways on
the external elevation would mean that
the neighboring properties would be
overlooked thus impacting on the quiet
enjoyment of residents finally the
lettering the fund Starts Here proposed
to sit upon above the building is
entirely not in keeping within the
conservation area it is completely
unnecessary and dare I say tacky for
these reasons I would urge the committee
to refuse the planning application thank
you
thank you very much
speaking in favor of this application is
Cabinet member councilor Pugh
foreign
I come to you before members of the
planning committee
today in my role as a Cabinet member for
economic development and I called in
this application to committee because I
believe that this is a very good use of
this site of particularly of a
Brownfield site in Margate Town Center
um
people have spoken about signs and
distractions and not in keeping with the
area around the corner on Marine Terrace
we've got the big Flamingo sign which
used to be illuminated many years ago I
think part of that and maybe part of why
the sign has been included is it's part
of the kind of you know the
uh the kind of the thriving nature of
Margate as a Seaside town and why many
people come to the area and come and
visit and have fond memories of coming
to Margate
and I you know in my view I don't feel
that this will have a negative impact
particularly on Heritage on the
conservation area I do understand that
it's cited within the Margate
Conservation area but at the same time I
think this is an incredibly inventive
and interesting design
um and I'd like it very similar to uh
the Margate contemporary to turn a
contemporary story
um probably shouldn't get the name of
that wrong it's definitely the turn of
contemporary
um in that there were many residents
that may have been concerned about the
proposed designs or return a
contemporary many years ago and now it's
almost you know a natural part of of the
frontage
um along Margate Harbor there and I
think it looks fantastic
I think considering the pressures that
we have on developments particularly on
agricultural land I think that the use
of a Brownfield site in one of our town
centers in this not just inventive way
but in the surrounding area there are
many uh commercial and Retail units that
now have flats above them I think this
is the way that postcovids we need to be
encouraging people to move back into our
town centers to come back into our town
centers and live in the town centers and
I think that this application and these
proposals really embody that
I acknowledge that the design and the
colorings are quite striking but again
you know I think that uh much of
architectural design has always pushed
the envelope and the boundaries of what
should be accepted and I think that
should be applauded for it
it's mentioned within uh the officer's
report and the recommendation and on
fears of height and whilst I appreciate
the heights uh an increase in height can
be a concern particularly in the
adjoining building uh next to it
uh that kind of faces uh Marine Terrace
and the roads coming up here to Cecil
Square you know the building itself will
be no taller than that and I wouldn't
say that that's necessarily A striking
height and of course if you're facing if
you've got the entrance to Dreamland
behind you across the other side of
belgrave road and you're looking at this
proposal site right behind you in the
distance we've got Arlington house and
you know nothing is ever going to dwarf
the height of that so I'm a bit
concerned that one of the reasons for a
recommendation refusal is height when
this is nowhere near
um as tall as as probably one of the
tallest Towers on the Isle of thanet
it's mentioned as well within the
recommendation of a refusal
um apologies chair I will sum up uh the
recreational pressure on the thanic
coast now I you know I think that this
is a null and void point because we need
to be encouraging people to live closer
to the Sea um and enjoy
um our Coastline and tied in with that
the amount of money that is coming into
the area and investment and with the
Margate Town deal and Margate digital I
think we'd be absolutely mad to refuse
this application particularly when
somebody wants to come along and wants
to better use a Brownfield site in a
town center where we want people to come
back and live so thank you chair
uh thank you Council Pugh I have done
that Council of fellows wish to possibly
speak on this uh Council presence on
20.1 yeah I think Chet and thank you
members I'm a Margate boy brought up in
Margate in cliftonville a Margate is in
my heart the same as yourself chair over
the last several years I've watched
Margate rejuvenate and but I'm not sure
where Margaret is on the ladder of
regeneration near the middle one I'd say
maybe I guess and we've had to rely on
inward investment and grants to continue
this rejuvenation
it's a long road you know 40 Years of
Decay he's not going to be reversed
overnight
now I didn't really taken much notice of
this application until recently when I
was surprised to see in the local news
report that it was up for refusal surely
this scheme is uh will be a start of a
rejuvenation for this area Margate it's
a Brownfield site as such an empty space
above a commercial unit sure this is
this is the kind of development we
should be encouraging and such
investment would bring up this area
this also could be a catalyst for
further regeneration close by I think
refusal would send out the wrong message
to investors as well
planning officers determine the proposal
of this scheme to be incongruous I had
to look up the dictionary meaning of in
Congress it says not in harmony or in
keeping with the surroundings or other
aspects of something well opposite is a
theme park a car park around the corners
Kebab shops opposite is a row of
flashing lights above Amusement arcades
weatherspoons Etc
so I'm not sure where it's not keeping
in harmony
um in just a few months time as well I'm
sure the same officers will encouraging
you to allow thousands of houses on
beautiful green fields of Westgate and
birchington there's going to be nothing
more in Congress as that
so as a counselor I support this
application I must say no connection
with anybody here involved in this
application as well so thank you thank
you councilor fellows
um I'll ask the plan in office now to
detail the report please and I believe
it's in
thank you chair
the application site is outlined in Red
so the application is for the
Redevelopment of the site including
three commercial units on the ground
floor with a three-story extension above
the existing building creating a total
of 10 Flats the main considerations for
members are the principal development
the impact on the character appearance
of the area the specific the reference
to the conservation area and the
adjacent listed buildings as well as
highways concerns and all other
environmental considerations under the
plumbing Act
um so the site as mentioned is located
within the Margate Conservation Area
there is the Margate seafront
Conservation area which is the the
dividing line is down belgrave row so
it's the other side of the road and the
nearest enlisted buildings are in red on
that plan so you've got
12 and 12 a
marine
marine Gardens so not Terrace I was
going to get that wrong at some point
started early
um so the site behind is worth
mentioning because that's actually an
allocated housing site in the current
local plan with a notional number of
dwellings for six for that site again no
no committed development on that site so
but it's just for reference for members
so they're aware
so this is the photo the site itself
from belgrave Road
uh you can see at the moment obviously
the the business I'm sure most members
are very familiar with this site
uh this is a view just further back so
you can see uh flamingo in the left-hand
side there the blue building uh you can
see the rear of uh 12a there and then
you've got uh Eaton Road and Eaton Hill
on the right hand side
so then looking from Dreamland car park
you've got the building there
and then this is the view looking from
in front of the site elevation of the
the Flamingo back towards the building
you can see the scaffolding on 12a
Marine Gardens and you've got the view
from adjacent to the Clock Tower so you
can see Flamingo and then the listed
Terrace on the left-hand side
and you can see the building in the gap
down belgrave Road
and then this is the view further across
the other side of the road did a show
again the height of those buildings on
the sea front and the perspective that
you've got the view through there
um so this is a more detailed View at
the back of a marine Gardens so you can
see the the window Arrangement you can
see the the Gap with the sort of single
story unit at ground floor between the
the two buildings
so
this is now a view looking from Eaton
Road so you can see in the distance uh
the rear of 12 and 12a
um has mentioned so and what will be
quite small on the image um but you can
see the pitch of the roof where the
mouse pointer is there which is the
existing single story building
and then this is a view down Eaton Hill
so the single story sort of high single
story building with the the corrugated
iron roof is not part of this site so
it's directly adjacent to the building
so the building in question is the one
with the Gable at the end uh and the the
support hole window in it
so you can see there's quite a
significant level difference when you
come down Eaton Hill
um so with the buildings single story
that obviously lowered down
and then just did some aerial images
just to give you the context so I think
again members would be very familiar
with with where this is
um so as mentioned Eaton Hill was was
just where we were looking at the site
from you've obviously got Margate
seafront Marine Gardens
and then just give you the isometric
View
from Google you can see
um property in row number two set back
from the frontage and then you can see
again the properties on Eaton Hill
running down and the site to the rear as
mentioned as well as then the back of
the properties on Marine Gardens
and then this is the view looking back
the other way so you can see then the
back of the properties
um on the Terrace
um with the flamingo again
and you can see that single story
building and that the site obviously
extends all the way down to the back of
number 12a
so this is a perspective view that's
been submitted by the applicant of The
Proposal we'll go through the the
precise plans to be built but I thought
it'd be worth starting with this image
so it's a obviously a modern design
building but it's building on top of the
existing structure so you can see the
Gable of the existing building there
um so it's as mentioned commercial on
ground floor there are three units
there's also parking on ground floor for
the flats above so the frontage at
ground floor would be painted brickwork
with as mentioned that black windows and
and the uh the sort of shutter doors
then at first and second floor you have
um yellow clad brick and then at the
rear and then on the the highest floor
you've got the orange vertical metal
cladding with front balconies all the
way across the front and as the
aforementioned signage right at the top
of the building
so looking at the plans themselves
um we've got the existing block plan
here
um the whole site is being developed so
it's literally on top of the existing
building there with the the three-story
extension
so then you've got the existing Western
elevation so this is the the belga of
Road Frontage elevation uh and then this
is the proposal so the ridge height of
the existing building is being increased
obviously the very tip of that pitched
uh that Gable end is being increased by
about 6.8 meters with the similar
increase in the eaves height
um with the overall Eaves height though
from the existing eavesite increasing to
about 9.5 meters now currently there is
obviously as I mentioned there's an
existing building on the site
um this has been looked at in terms of
whether or not what the impact of that
building has on the conservation area
obviously you've seen from the images
there's lots of adverts on the front
it's obviously been changed over time
it's got a very commercial Frontage but
obviously the side elevations do retain
some of the original brickworks so in a
sort of balanced approach we think this
is sort of neutral impact on the
conservation area but obviously they are
proposing to retain it and obviously
retain in those side elevations which
will obviously be visible when looking
at this proposal
so looking at the side elevation of the
building so this is the existing
elevation I was just talking about so
that you can see the back of the list of
properties behind
um so this is the site elevation so
again the front element which is set in
from the frontage Ridge balconies is the
brick clad element first and second
floor uh and then the orange metal
cladding is the predominant part of the
side elevation here
um so this is where the this side
elevation is not set in
um significantly from the existing side
of the building presently on site so
this is the the create a full four-story
building on the Eaton Hill elevation
this is the existing rear elevations
this is the East Elevation
and then this is the rear elevation as
proposed so the main access to the flat
effectively create the walkways at the
rear as as mentioned so what you've got
here is metal cross braces and with
Timber cladding on the element on the
right hand side of the image that you
can see which is the stair core so we'll
look at the the floor plan so you can
see that
um
so we've also got then the inset
elevation at the top there so you can
actually see that this is where the the
doors and windows actually are for for
accessing the flats and again we'll look
at the floor plan so you can see that in
a bit more detail and there's a
perspective later on to kind of give you
the material palette
uh so this is the north elevation
existing so this is the one that faces
the the list of buildings
um so again similar in design in the
sense of the the
brick cladding the yellow brick cladding
to the front of the extension but with
the orange metal cladding to the rear
um now the middle element here that you
can see whether I hope the mouse pointer
is and the front elements are set in
from this side of the ocean so you'll
see on the floor plans that these have
been set in which was following concerns
that officers have raised about the
impact on the listed building these
elements were set in in discussions
um then you've got this is a section
just showing the different levels
internally so this is that elevation
that North elevation
um there's The Terraces that you can see
at um at second floor level and then
you've got the balconies at the front of
first floor second floor and then the
Terrace and front balcony at the top
floor and again we'll look at the floor
plans to show that relationship with the
neighbors a bit more detail
so this is the proposed Street Scene
just compare the two so you can see the
the listed building on the left hand
side obviously with the advert which
you'll have seen from the photos so you
can see that the full scale of the
building so
the concerns that officers have relate
to the scale and sort of ensuing design
that almost comes out of the scale and
the impact that has on the conservation
area and the impact on the setting of
the list of buildings so in our view the
scale competes with the listed Terrace
um belgrave road is is not the seafront
it's not in that hierarchy in terms of
pattern of development historically and
therefore we do feel that this is
conflicting with the predominant form
and Heritage assets in the conservation
area
now in terms of
um the scale of the building
um obviously it has been articulated so
you saw from side elevations that are
Frontage at first for the second floor
um are sort of well first and second and
set back the same amount but with
balconies and then the third floor is
set back for sort of even further with
the articulation setting at the side
which you can now sort of see from this
elevation here on the left-hand side of
the bottom image
we don't consider that this would
actually alleviate the bulk and scale of
the building that's being proposed with
the choice of materials making the
building even more prominent and I mean
that is the point of it
um but obviously we have particular
concerns about that and indeed the
Integrity of of actually the The
Proposal as it is in terms of the design
itself we fill the building at the
moment has quite a horizontal emphasis
but obviously it is very low lying it
doesn't impact on the the general form
of development you have in the area
which broadly has a vertical emphasis
when looking at the the style of
fenestration that you've got in the
buildings obviously you can see the
building on that elevation of on on two
Eden Hill and that is pretty common when
you go down the roads which are more
residential than they are commercial
behind the seafront and the the change
in the horizontal emphasis that the
proposal would have with quite a top
heavy design would in our view appear
bulky in its context and overall that is
of concern in terms of the side
elevation from Eaton Hill
we saw from the image the fact that
there is a change in levels as you go
down Eaton Hill and obviously this is an
elevation that sits almost flush with
the side elevation of the existing
building and this would then become a a
four-story building and almost you know
a full four-story building with a very
different material to the palette of
materials that you find in the area so
we do consider that would be out of
keeping in scale and kind with the
development in the locality in this more
residential side uh or to the south of
the seafront and so that is considered
to result in harm in in our view now in
terms of the benefits the development
and obviously what it is providing I'm
just going to go through the proposed
units of accommodation so as mentioned
there are 10 parking spaces that are
provided at the ground floor
um you can see that
you have one large commercial unit in
the middle of the building and then two
smaller commercial units
um in the the sort of still having sort
of shop frontages on the left hand side
you've got the stair core you've got bin
storage you've got cycle storage uh
serving the flats
so then you've got the first floor here
so you can see the stair core at the
rear as mentioned with that first
walkway you can see that's the access to
the flats as mentioned all the units
have balconies at the front so we are in
a town center location these are two and
three bed units
um it is obviously very difficult when a
site is fully developed to provide
private immunity space and therefore
even though none is directly provided
with these amenity spaces we wouldn't
think there is a reason to suggest that
the accommodation is substandard in any
way they are all you know sizable units
that are being proposed and and that
will provide a benefit by virtue of the
housing that it provides
um however looking at the relationship
with neighbors is a particular concern
with regards to the Terrace and
obviously you've already heard the
um the applicant's representative
mentioning about the potential for for
privacy screens the concern of offices
relates to the left-hand side of the
image that you're seeing
um specifically the fact that the
Terrace obviously extends all the way to
the side the rear and you will have seen
from the photos the fact that you have
rear-facing windows at the back of 12a
and 12 that face directly towards this
site
um they are
um that that those two units are 12 and
12a constitute uh six Flats at first
second third forever in total all with
windows that face out including uh
bedroom windows
um at second and and so forth level
um and then this is the top floor
again showing the Terrace area on the
left-hand side but then again showing
these are two units so these are
obviously very large units
um with the external walkway at the rear
so this is the proposed roof plan so you
can see the articulation different
design that you've got there in terms of
the pictures that have been proposed
um just to go back to the the 3D
representations that have been provided
these are useful in showing the
different articulations although we
would obviously ask members to make sure
that look at the sections and the Street
Scenes rather than sort of the actual
relationship with other buildings
um because these haven't been verified
by officers as being Acura but it is
important to see the the different
articulation that is being proposed in
the building and that that palette of
materials that's that's being shown
so this is the rear elevation so this is
to give you a bit more of an idea so the
walkway is being covered by these
elements obviously this is a a concern
of officers in terms of the view down
um you know Eaton Hill due to the scale
of the building that is being proposed
so in the report it outlines the
additional requirements of this type of
development and there are consultique
comments which include a number of
conditions which would be recommended to
be put on if the application was to be
approved highways have commented that
they consider the fact that they've
provided 10 parking spaces sufficient
for the accommodation that's been
provided and indeed it is in a
effectively a town center location our
off-street parking would not be required
for a development such as this it's very
sustainably located so it is a benefit
to provide the the 10 units
um as already outlined
um about a few speakers there are
planning obligations that will be
required for development of this scale
as well as a contribution towards the
the special protection area and the
mitigation to avoid increased
recreational pressure which would mean
the development would be contrary to the
habitat regs but overall in conclusion
officers consider that there is benefit
for 10 units being provided here and
that is a contribution to housing Supply
but is consider design and scale that
the development would result in harm to
the conservation area and the setting of
listed buildings whilst resulting in
overlooking to the neighboring property
and therefore is recommended for refusal
thank you chair thank you Ian I move the
officer's recommendation could the vice
chair please second oh second nature
thank you councilman cook Council
Quinton
thank you I find myself agreeing almost
entirely with councilor Pew on this one
um I like the design I like the colors I
like the way it ties in with the the
seafront
yeah
it's like the first time I've ever heard
that in the chamber
we might we might disagree on a bunch of
white boxes down the road but um which
you've praised
um but I do think uh actually it is a
very positively designed
um it fits in with the area I appreciate
that I'm looking at the conservation
area next to it as drawn on the lines
but all in all
um I I like it I like the the design and
the impact and I don't and we we see how
modern architecture can sit alongside
historic areas very well in in other
areas if you you go down the Thames or
whatever
and I don't see any reason why this
which does tie in very well with our
seafront image um should be any
different to that so I like it
thank you very much cancer regret
yeah thank you chair there are four
reasons for refusal um offered by the
officers um and I would suggest that two
three and four are pretty much Beyond
argument
um two refers to
um direct overlooking which I don't
think this committee ought to be
sanctioning uh three refers to the lack
of the legal agreement secure delivery
of the planning obligations and
um for uh refers to the same
contribution which is obligatory with
new Housing Development none of which
are in front of us so I think this
committee is in no position to approve
this application I have to say
um so I think we ought to revision it I
do have some sympathy with the debate
about what it looks like and whether
it's in keeping with the area and the
effect on the um
Conservation Area adjacent I'm not quite
sure what I think about it to be honest
with you I think it's one of those that
you really need to to to to think about
um in the round
um I don't think it's impossible to put
a taller building on that site
um I find its appearance quite garish
but then I think that the existing
building is fairly unpleasant as it
looks in the state that it's in so
um I think it has balance those two
things up I'll be interested to see what
members I've say but I think uh this
committee is in no position to approve
this application tonight in my opinion
thank you cancer every Cancer heart
hey chair um
it's a very difficult
decision this one because I
counselor Crittenden and I quite often
agree but I must disagree with that in
this in this circumstance I think it's
over development I think it's too tall
for the area and I think it's the most
ugliest building we've ever seen
um I just think it's too garish myself
but uh I do agree with cancer ever as
well I think it's a very difficult one
to call should we be approving it not
too sure
um but I think if we're going to put
something in this position it should I
don't object to Modern
um but I just think it's too tall too
overdeveloped and possibly could be
toned down just a bit
thank you Chad thank you Council Council
Keen
thank you chair yeah we've got a range
of views tonight I don't mind the height
of it I can see it being in that
location quite comfortably but I do
think the colors of the design they're
just gaudy a few years down the line I
think it would look very tacky and
therefore I think it's out of keeping
with that area a nice light modern
design would be fine but I I can't
approve of what the proposal is also
where where is this the fun starts here
going
thank you
so that's it on the roof
at the moment
councilor woman
yeah thank you chair um interesting
isn't it it's an interesting development
uh
proposal
um
I actually think that it is it does
appear to be bulky and
um
part the original Conservation Area is
to enhance the area
that's what it's that's that's
legislation you should be looking to
enhance the area
now obviously there's a point as a point
of view
um
some people may say in ounces and some
people might say it doesn't
um it would certainly uh brighten up the
area and it actually that is for sure
um
I I'm just mindful of what the
applicant's agent said at the start of
this uh
item chair that
um they were willing to enter into
agreement in relation to section 106 etc
etc
so
if as well so I think we need to bear
that in mind and maybe
members might decide that that it should
go back to offices before a decision is
taken to to iron out those issues to as
to what the agent has said
um I would appreciate if uh Mr Lewis who
could take us back to the rear
that one we'll come back so I mean that
is um well that's just barking mad
that'd be quite honest and I don't think
that fits in and enhances the area at
all so I I think that the uh
the the applicant needs to rethink this
I've got no problem with the bulk I've
got no problem with the height
etc etc
the only other issue that I have and I
just spotted it and uh
emulation we're talking about adverts
and all that kind of stuff
what's what's on the top
if you go back to number 12 I
you got a large advert holding on the
side of a grade two listed building
so it's obviously been there donkey she
is
um but the council can take action to
get rid of that
um so I'm just saying I I it is
difficult
but I think overall
um
I can't support it purely because of the
rear elevation the rest I think is
absolutely fine
councilman counselor wing
I'm conflicted because I think 80 I'm
okay with this and if you look at the
objections it was it was certain
elements of the build that I find are in
conflict with the the with either the
neighbors or the the conservation area
so I'm I'm bang on with cancer album the
back just looks mad uh I don't I don't
understand the back the back openness of
the back at all that definitely is well
what's going on here the sign I don't
understand on the top either there's no
there's no relevance to the building or
to the surrounding
but I think it's I think it's a good use
of a of a piece of land I I work on the
fact that we're putting additional
residential units in there there's
parking on site the waste seems to be
dealt with two of the issues that we
that we often bring up
I I don't think and the issues that that
Council River brought up need addressing
and I think maybe the developer or the
applicant just needs to rethink things
and tweak
listen listen to the objections and
listen to what we're saying and maybe
tweak those things I definitely think
the colors are are
I can accept something that's different
because I think we need to create new
Heritage uh that for the future but I
think maybe this that the colors don't
fit with me fit well with me I love the
fact they've kept the part of the old
Heritage and built into the block on on
the end so I'm sort of 80 we're there
but but that 20 needs to be addressed I
think to make it the full full thing so
I think I'm probably going to vote for
refusal but I hope it comes back
being tweaked if that makes sense hey
Council Wing Council Byford
to some some extent but for me it's
imaginative and most appropriate use of
a Brownfield site offering 10 units of
much needed housing with parking as well
as commercial units
Margate now offers a mix of traditional
retro and modern architectural design
and the present site is run down and not
aesthetically pleasing at all
I believe we should be encouraging such
an exciting development and and
encouraging investment into the area
thank you thank you Council very fair
Council Dave
thank you chairman
um and um I've looked at the report
and I've listened to the arguments
um members will know that I tend to be a
little bit of a traditionist
um
and on that basis I don't think the
conservation argument stands up for
scrutiny based on what we've seen and
based on knowing the area
I'm also not a great
fan of industrial style architecture but
I've accepted it elsewhere and it does
blend in and I think something that
looks very garish on day one can grow on
you I wasn't a fan of the Turner
contemporary design I thought the one
that fell into the sea was Far Far More
aesthetically pleasing
um
but on the basis of looking at what
we're being offered and um the
investment that's being put forward and
having listened to the
applicant's agent with regards to the
preambles
I'm minded not to support the planning
office's recommendation I think that
this needs as other members have said I
think this needs to go back I think we
need to have some rethought on some of
the items I think we need more
information on some of the items I'm not
proposing that the color scheme gets
amended because I'm sure that we would
um
learn to live with that sort of
colorance coming I'm afraid
traditionally Islam it's going to change
and things are going to change so at
this point in time I'm not going to
support the office's recommendation
thank you I think councilor Saunders uh
cancer right
fun this this building will bring back
the fun to Margate
thank you
Council Ghana
thanks yeah I mean I can agree with a
lot of what's been said
um by a number of members about the need
for for these 10 units and the need for
that site to be developed but
as Council Everett said I don't think we
can get away I can we can discount
um points three and four because they
could they they could be sorted out with
the applicant but we can't get away from
point two which is that there is
overlooking on on on one side of the
building that is unacceptable so
if we want this to be developed then I
guess we do need to refuse it and go
back to the to the drawing board to get
it
to get it um redesigned
um appropriately and I guess my one
question I would have is I assume there
have been some conversations
have there with the applicant about this
any two of them throw in about what word
or what wouldn't wouldn't be acceptable
um maybe that that is my question have
there been conversations and if there
hasn't then can there be can I I'm sorry
I know I'm not allowed to speak but they
have we've been very frustrated that we
haven't been able to have any
conversations I must stop you there
I know you understand another word but
if you don't mind
um
come back just a few Council
um thanks I think there's the cloud fire
with regards to
um the reasons for refuse obviously
um the motion on the table is to refuse
with the foregrounds if
if members were to vote down that motion
um then obviously members could propose
a motion to effectively give back to
officers to look at the issues that have
been raised and specific reference those
issues to potentially invite amended
plans I think
um in terms of the engagement point the
council did have pre-application
discussions with the applicant and did
provide comments on uh the the
development as proposed and did raise
issues with the scale in terms of
um in terms of The Proposal obviously
reference has been made and Amendments
have been received when the application
came in for the the different
articulation in terms of you can see in
the image there on the left-hand side
but we didn't consider that to be
sufficient to alleviate the overall
concerns we have with with the
development
uh thank you Ian Council Crittenden
uh yeah I'd just like to add to my
comments earlier I do agree with my
colleagues about the um the view from
the rear it is not actually as good as
the view from the front
thank you Council roses
yeah thank you chair uh looking at it I
think the um applicants
um
uh spokesperson I mentioned that the
screening can be done to cure any over
overlooking
um on that side of the building so not
not to begin issue
um again as my colleagues were saying
that this is a big investment for
Margate a lot of uh money be spent to
produce 10 homes and
um extra
commercial business business units
downstairs
um I think this is something that we've
got to you know look forward to and and
regeneration is going to be something
that Margate Ramsgate and in broadstairs
is going to need at some point and
therefore
um I'd be looking at uh going against
the offices of advice on this thank you
chair uh thank you cancer roses
um looking around
[Music]
can't see any other members wish to
speak
um thank you members
um right I put this to you the
recommendation
is to refuse those who wish to refuse
this could they please show
sorry
yes fine
results okay and there is again
any absentions
right I'm looking to my colleague here
five five nine okay so it's Fallen yeah
right that has fallen
so I'm coming to Ian on this game please
um
so
members have a number of options do you
want
Council Robbins already put his hand up
that's all
yeah yeah probably uh Mr Livingston is
gonna
say what I want him to say see what I
mean
no pressure and that is and that is
chair for the for the the things that
members have brought forward in relation
to the this development uh for further
discussions to take place and for this
to be referred back to officers uh for
discussions with the uh applicants
agents concerning uh
the the reasons for refusal to overcome
those so I think I think we're all most
of us are agreed that uh that this
development should take place and I
would just make one commentary if I if I
may
um which is against what people have
told talked about but um just because
someone's pumping money and it doesn't
necessarily mean that we've got to
approve it because they're pumping money
in it's got to be right
and it's because otherwise you can end
up with loads of rubbish but I do think
that this could be something that would
be agreeable within Margate and within
that space thank you chair thank you
councilor Auburn uh take on board what
you started with there
um is that a proposal
is if probably if Mr Livingston would um
would file it around and make it uh
sound better more legible
thank you chair
um the
I I think the one thing I'd say is that
there are a lot of different elements
that members have mentioned so some
members have different concerns
obviously mentioned to the rear
elevation some members are concerned
about the scale some members are
concerned about the the pallet of
materials and whether they need to be
turned down
um obviously the application is here to
hear those concerns
um and
um I think the motion
to put what you've said into words would
be effectively for it to be deferred to
officers to seek amendments to address
the concerns of members with regards to
and I'm going to keep it quite generic
the impact on the character of the area
um and then to be brought back to
members for determination uh yeah you
need a second look at that if casserole
you've heard that members
um obviously there are a few concerns
can understand uh some of them
um could show hands please those
those against that
I think you're on your own the accounts
and payford am I making sense I'm sorry
you've heard what has been said about
uh going back to the applicant with what
we mentioned here tonight with possibly
a few changes
um with what's been stated of concerns
has been proposed by councilor Auburn
Council by
councilor Everett
are you happy that that happens or are
you not
so in favor of the applications
from
the cold air my idea was that this was
to refuse permission and that felt so
therefore position has been yeah
please members please
yeah so there's currently no motion on
the table so it's not automatically
refused if the motion has fallen a new
motion has to be proposed before a
decision is reached so if members agree
uh with Council Auburn's motion they
would vote in support of it however if
you actually disagree and you think it
should be refused or you think it should
be approved outright as it is you would
disagree with that motion to seek those
amendments but obviously what we're
trying to find is an overall perspective
of members to potentially take back to
the applicant thank you
I'm sorry
right do members understand now what's
been said and that's what I was trying
to get over to you a proposal has been
put forward it's been seconded I've
asked you to vote on that
if you agree with that proposal please
show
totally fine
that was against
oh that has been carried
thank you members
okay
thank you members agenda item for C
which is number 45 Stanley Road
broadstairs
speaking in favor of this application is
Mr Philip Lewis Mr Lewis are you there
yep thank you Mr chairman thank you you
have three minutes Mr Lewis thank you
okay
um yes I'm my name is Philip Lewis I'm
the owner of 45 Stanley Road uh Stanley
Road has an Eclectic mix of housing
evolved over a number of decades there
is no particularly common theme or
architectural style across the
properties it is not in the conservation
Zone nor an area of high townscape value
our house shares very few
characteristics with other properties in
the area and is in fact one of the least
attractive houses in the street it has
over large and poorly positioned Dormers
and an unattractive expansive roof
profile in short 45 Stanley is an
unimproved 1950s house now in much need
of renovation to bring it up to Modern
standards of Energy Efficiency safety
and comfort
we spend considerable time with local
Architects to develop an interesting
contemporary home with a carefully
considered understated appearance that
is intended to add variety and quality
of design in broadstairs
we have taken on the points made by the
planners to adjust the color scheme and
ensure the property does not
significantly extend the current
footprint
we have existing permitted development
permission for a two-story structure
plus Loft with a much higher Ridge line
please note the dashed line on the
proposed elevation you'll see later
however our proposal is a much more
modest alteration to the current
building retaining the existing Ridge
height with the exception of a small
Central skylight
the proposed Dormer is smaller in height
and deliberately asymmetrical both to
add interest and to Aid the display
diffusion within the property
in support of water conservation and
local biodiversity we're adding green
roofs and water capture
we are retaining the full Garden area
our neighbors are particularly pleased
that we are not building upon the garden
we're using local Builders and
responsibly sourced high quality
materials sympathetic to the area can
tiles Timber cladding locally
manufactured windows and doors
finally this is our home which we hope
to spend many years enjoying as stated
however it is an urgent need of repair
and Improvement we're proposing several
sustainable energy efficient features
fit for modern living
the planning layer is causing us
considerable stress and we do not relish
entering lengthy and costly appeals
process to achieve what we consider to
be a modest and sympathetic update to
our decrepit home
with extended delay the combined effects
of inflation erosion and material cost
risers May mean the project becomes
unaffordable for us
far from being severely detrimental to
the streetscape it is our belief that
our proposed improvements will enhance
the street scene with a carefully
considered well-constructed and
interesting addition to the bolster's
housing stock
we hope that committee will agree and
see fit to approve our plans thank you
thank you Mr Lewis overlasting out the
planning office which is excuse me Emma
to outline the application
thank you chairman uh this is the
application site here outlining red so
number 45 Stanley Road you can see it's
a detached property
um you can see Radley close over on the
right hand side here and you can see
they're quite large plots quite deep
Gardens
and this is the application property so
it's it's good sorry an existing uh
Shelly style Bungalows you can see
there's already accommodation at first
for level with an existing um door mud
to the center of the roof there's a
garage the front of the property and
that's projecting forward
and you can see this is the garage again
on the slide here you can see the barn
hip roof to the existing building this
is the neighboring property to the left
it also has a garage projection
and this is just the view again of the
application property on the left hand
side here so you can see the neighboring
property is also of similar Style with a
barn hit roof and what appears to be
accommodation again at roof level
and then a further away view again so
you can see the property in the middle
here with properties either side so you
can see in terms of the palette of
material it's mainly um red brick
um with a clay tiles although you can
see some white render as well on the
property to the left here
and then a further view so again the
predominant form of dreadings in this
Rhoda or Bungalows but mainly Chalet
sold Bungalows with the accommodation at
roof level so there's a variety of
different Dormers but you can see here
they're quite usually quite modest in
size
um within the roof slope
um this again is the application
property on the left here and again you
can see the the neighbor on the right
hand side so again similar reform
and this is the right hand side of the
application property so this is our
existing garage so this is the
neighboring property on the right and
you see their side window here so this
is just
um useful to know because there's a
proposed carport going in this location
here
and this is just showing again um
properties within the road so you can
see um again the majority of the Roadies
is Bungalows and again opposite the site
um the start of properties
and this is now into the reared Garden
of the application properties the
application properties on the right hand
side here looking um towards the
neighbor
um you can see again there's rear
Dormers in both the properties and this
here is a rear projecting
um a
the rear projection of the existing
garage on the side so the proposal is
for an extension of this garage
this is in the neighbor's property
looking back towards the application
site so this is the application site
here so this is just to show
um the nearest neighboring windows so
this is the boundary that you just saw
the existing garage adjacent to
um so the proposal is to extend that two
meters further so this is just showing
um the relationship with the noble
property you can see the existing
Windows Server dining room in this
location here
and then this is back inside the
application property so you can see the
existing Conservatory which um is
remaining and this is inside looking
towards the neighboring property here
from the conservatory and this is along
their side boundary so now this is with
the other neighboring property um who
are on the left hand side and there's um
this existing
um structure adjacent to the boundary
to the rear of the existing garage and
again just the view so this is the
neighbor this is the existing forward
projecting garage that you saw at the
site and then this is to the rear of
this and so the proposal include
includes enclosing this area here
and then again further back again so the
proposal will involve a projection of a
single story in this level here
so this is the proposed block plan
um so the proposal is to provide a
single store extension in this location
here and to extend the garage in this
location here and to provide a carport
at the front of the site and at roof
level it's to provide an enlarged Dormer
um to the front and at the rear and to
Gable the ends of the building so this
is the existing front elevation of the
building as you saw from the photos so
you can see again the existing Barn hit
reform the central Dorma and the forward
garage projection and again on the right
hand side the other garage which is
currently set back behind the front
elevation and this is the proposal so
the proposal involves on the right hand
side a carport which will be an open car
port
um through this application there have
been a number of amendments that have
been received so the Amendments have
included the carpool on the right hand
side being set back so it's in line with
the neighboring property so there's now
no concern turns with this carport in
terms of its location on the left hand
side the existing garage that you saw
with a pitched roof the pitch roof has
been removed and it's been replaced with
a flat roof and then behind the garage
so this you can see there's a lower roof
here which is the existing garage and
then behind that an extension is being
built with a higher parapet roof
then at roof level the central Dormer is
being removed and it's been replaced
with this wider Dormer that extends
fully to the left-hand side of the
building and then you can see an
additional extension being added above
the roof with additional windows in it
so there's not actually any
accommodation at this level this has
just been added onto the property to
provide additional light into the first
floor first of all level
and you can see in terms of the actual
General appearance as well the the
materials of the building are changing
so again this has been amended
throughout the application but they're
currently proposed materials include
gray Timber cutting black chard Timber
cladding black framed aluminum windows
and red clay tiles
so this is the existing rear elevation
so again you can see the current rear
innovation has a central Dormer as well
and you can see the conservatory the um
the garage that extends up to the
boundary and
um the the lean tool on the side here
and this is now the proposal
so the proposal involves these two
Dormer windows being added at the rear
um again you can see the the raised
element at roof level here
um in this location here is an extension
to the rear of the garage so a two meter
extension on the boundary with the
neighbor and again in this location here
set further back from the rear because
it doesn't come fully out to the to the
rear elevation this is the extension
behind the existing front garage
so this is now the west facing elevation
so um so this was from the neighboring
side where I showed you a photo from
inside their Garden looking towards a
neighboring property
um so this is the proposed elevation
here so you can see the roof has gone
from a barn hip to a Gable end you can
see the Dormer windows and their profile
at the front and at the back there this
is the projecting car port so this front
elevation here of this carport was in
line with the neighboring front
renovation and then there's now a two
meter extension behind the existing
um Garage in this location here in terms
of the um Garage in this location so
it's not coming any further forward than
the existing garage but as you can see
the again the flat roof that's been
um removed oh sorry the picture if it's
been removed replaced with the flat roof
and again you can see the the cladding
changes
and then this is the other side of
innovation as existing and this is now
the elevation has proposed
um so one of the concerns really with
this elevation is with both of the
Dormers being um added at first floor
level that they're not centrally located
they're both up against this side wall
so there will be no break in the roof
form so you don't see the the um the
edge of the pitch roof you just see this
side elevation so creating
um a two-story element in this location
here as as was mentioned there has been
a prior approval that was submitted for
this um for this site for an additional
floor being added which is a system that
falls outside actual planning permission
that we can assess but is actually a
form of permitted development rights and
that that was approved and so the dotted
line is showing what was previously
allowed through the pry notification
process
um the concern with this though is not
necessarily the actual height of the
building the concern is with the over
form of the development the design of
the element and this additional roof
form being added at top top level and to
create the appearance of what has
appearance of a three-story building
so this is the section through the
building and again just another view
showing that section so similar and then
we're going to the floor plan so this is
the existing floor plans so again you
can see the existing floor with the
garage on the right hand side the
forward projecting garage here and the
conservator at the rear and this is now
the proposal so this is the extension in
this location here behind the existing
garage that's the extension that has a
raised parapet Roof then to the rear on
this side is another two meter deep
extension behind the existing garage
here is the carport
and then this is the existing first
floor plan so again because they have an
existing Dormer to the front and rear
this accommodation is already created at
first for level but this is the proposed
as a result of the change in the Dormers
so the Dormer is
um located on the left-hand side of the
front roof slope and the rear again
there's a dorm release location and this
location both projecting out
so there's no concerns with the
principle of a Dorma as you can see the
existing property has a Dorma there's
other properties in the street that have
a dormer so we have no concerns with the
accommodation at First full level and
again the prior notification has already
approved a two-story building so the
concern is with the design and the use
of materials and the overall appearance
of the building
um so with this additional floor being
added this has Windows located within it
as mentioned this then creates the
appearance of a what appears like a
three-story building in a road that is
full of Bungalows shall I saw Bungalows
so it will appear much larger in scale
than the other properties and with the
Dormer window again it's not whereas
existing dormant Windows within the
street are quite small and modest in
size centrally located within the
building this is quite a large scale and
Dorma it's um it's located on the left
hand side rather than centrally so it's
quite unbalanced on the building
and the use of the black clad in
um throughout the building and the gray
cladian is considered to be a material
that's not in keeping with the existing
palette of material in the surrounding
area
so
um there's no concerns with the um the
garage extension in this location here
in terms of the impacts on the neighbor
whilst it does come out the additional
two meters and as you saw from the photo
it's not considered that would have a
significant impact on neighboring light
given the boundary treatment that's
there and and what's present in the
neighboring Garden that screens the
extension in terms of the extension on
this hat this side as well this isn't
the neighbor's garage so there's a three
and a half meter gap between the
proposal and the side window of the
neighboring property but the majority of
their
um room windows are at the rear and this
doesn't project Beyond there so again
the actual extension itself is not
considered to impact on the neighbor's
living conditions and even the um the
gabling of the roof what this is
considered to be adequate distance from
neighboring Windows to not result in any
unacceptable impact but the concern is
with this design and the fact it will um
through the Dormers and the additional
roof element appear out of character of
the area and then what's recommended for
refusal thank you
thank you very much Emma I move the
officer's recommendation uh could the
vice chair please second oh second
nature thank you Council Carmen cook
members
Casa Ghana
yeah oh so I'll I'll go first thing all
right okay
that's right no I'm I'm
I mean I'm struggling more with this one
than the previous one in terms of
agreeing that this should be refused
um
I mean I I a previous planning committee
meetings I've
been quite Keen to preserve
um areas that have a predominance of
Bungalows a bungalow estate that I've
been quite Keen to protect but this has
been a this I think there's been some a
slight
um
no I won't say misinformation but a
slight difference and what about Stanley
Road that I think isn't fully understood
Stanley Road isn't a road of Bungalows
it's quite a long road with some quite
large houses this one
so I am quite familiar with Stanley Road
this one is sort of on the edge of where
the houses come up to and then the
Bungalow star so I think it's a bit a
bit unfair to say that this is
um this is changing
the character of the area
um and especially as
there is already permission as I
understand it for a development here
that would actually be larger than what
this development is higher than what
this development is so and I think one
of the things
that is in its favor as well I think
councilor Auburn mentioned and when we
were discussing the previous proposal
um that you know the style and and
um
style and design is in in the eye of the
beholder and you know what my oh no it's
Council of Saunders so I always get the
two of you mix up
is in the eye the behold on what one day
what one day might not be like you know
is is something that
is going to change and I mean I quite
like this design and the look of this
and I think it would be a shame to to
refuse permission for it that's my
contribution for now thank you Council
Carla Council well I'm pleased to hear
from councilor Garner about the street
scene because actually that was one of
the things that I was was going to ask
but you you've kind of already answered
that I think my first reaction when I
saw the bit on top was like
um but the more you've shown me pictures
of it the more it's grown on me and um
actually I do quite like it I think um
as long as it doesn't detract hugely
from the street scene
um I'm inclined to agree with councilor
Garner
thank you Council Everett
well these things very much in the eye
of the beholder I have to say I agree
with the planning officers I think it's
unbalanced
um I think perhaps that drawing doesn't
do it any favors in terms of trying to
understand the building but it looks
distinctly odd to me and therefore I'm
I'm inclined to view it will be in
Congress in this street scene or any
Street Scene
um and I think I support the
recommendation to refuse it on that
basis thank you thank you Council right
thank you um I'm I I really don't like
it
um it is totally upkeeping with a house
it looks more can looks more like an
industrial unit but one thing that is
missing for me is there's no mention of
things like a water table what kind of
energy it's going to be used it it when
you when you do the development like
this it's a perfect opportunity to put
the all singing or dancing
climate-friendly facilities in it thank
you
thank you Council bayford
nature
what we like I don't think it's just
about what we like it's too subjective I
think we have to consider
whether from the planning point of view
this is acceptable and it is different
but that can't be denied but as pointed
out by counselor Garner and councilor
Crittenden
um
it it's the street scene is not all
about Bungalows and so I really think
it's quite harsh to refuse this thank
you thank you Council Dave's almost
thank you chairman
um I too know Stanley Road and the
particular and it's absolutely right
that this Chalet Bungalow Is On The
Fringe of the area that is predominantly
Bungalows and directly opposite
um the estate directly opposite starts
with Bungalows
um
members will know from the past when
I've been on this committee I do like a
bit of symmetry and I do agree with
councilor Everett that while I'm looking
at that elevation
there's no
symmetry with the ridge line and quite
honestly you might as well have that
dawn of the full width of the rear
elevation so
I agree with the planning officer I
don't actually like the
um sort of third story
um look out on the top there and knowing
that area of Stanley Road knowing what's
adjacent to it with the Dutch style roof
Etc I do believe it's a nice
architectural design on a prime site
this isn't a prime site it's a it's a
large residential area and I do agree
with the pending officers recommendation
that it will be out of character sadly I
think on another site is absolutely
superb but where it is and where it's
being planned I agree with the planning
officer it will be out of sight so I'll
be supporting the recommendation for
refusal thank you Council and someone
does as uh councilor harp
um
it is a mom right I live in a
a chalet Bungalow if you want to call it
and it is very difficult sometimes to
have enough room in a roof to actually
put what you want into a roof so I have
sympathy with the people who are
actually putting their application in
because I have small Dormers in the
front of my
um
I do know the road and I think Mr
Garner's quite correct because gone is
quite correct um
and I it is we shouldn't be judging
these on taste whether we like it or
whether we don't and that is what I
think one of us some of us tonight are
trying to decide at the end of the day
does this have a merit in its place
um I think it should but I can't really
say we should refuse it just because it
doesn't look right I mean not being
funny I think we have to be Forward
Thinking I think we have to actually
make sure that
um we're making houses that are fit and
useful for today's market and by
changing the use of this building to one
that is practical and fit for purpose
then I think that's what we should be
doing chair thank you thank you Council
Wayne I I just like to say I think that
the applicant did say that they were put
in energy saving stuff in if I heard
right and that it was going to be made
more eco-friendly which is good to hear
I also like the fact the garden isn't
going to be touched so there's no over
development in terms of sprawl out into
what is clearly a beautiful garden and a
Haven for wildlife I I I you know I I I
can drive down dumpton Park Drive for
example and see buildings like this that
have appeared between a very traditional
looking buildings and maybe the
disadvantage this this proposal's got is
it is the first one on the street I I
think we're all of a certain age and I
think maybe we need to start looking
looking to approve things that maybe are
a bit more modern modern looking they
might be out of keeping slightly with
the with with with the Bungalows and the
houses around them which are all very it
appears of an individual design so in
that respect it fits into the street
because every house seems to be
specifically designed that there doesn't
seem to be a set pattern of of housing
so I I will be voting against refusal uh
thank you councilwin a little bit
concerned about of a certain age but um
are there any other members wish to
speak okay I'm going to put this once
again to you
um the application is for refusal those
in favor of that recommendation please
show
those against
their motion is lost
so I'm going to turn to the office again
thank you
um thank you
um so it's as always if a motion for
refusal Falls where the motion being put
forward against officer recommendation
it has to be given as a ground for why
it's being approved I think from the
discussion it's very clear that members
um actually think this wouldn't appear
out of character or certainly wouldn't
cause harm to the character and
appearance of the area those that
support it and so if emotion is to be
put forward for approval it would be on
the grounds that it wouldn't harm the
the character of the area
um I'm just looking at my colleague to
wonder whether or not there will be any
other conditions that we would recommend
um
pretty clear isn't it
I think given that nature of the plans
and the detail we've got we wouldn't
recommend any other conditions
thank you and God's gone
um I'm happy to propose what Mr
Livingstone has just suggested proposal
thank you yep a second to please
several hands I could be counselor wing
and it's to approve those in favor
thank you we'll see who's against
all right that's correct thank you thank
you for that members
[Music]
thank you members
um moving on to agenda item
for oh
yeah sorry
come back
outside of word
right and right before D which is land
of adjacent to 12 14 Fort Road uh
speaking in favor of the application is
Mr miles Mr miles you have three minutes
please
good evening members and thank you for
allowing me to speak on this item it's
been interesting to observe the other
applications that you've dealt with
tonight and I'll comment on those
perhaps a bit later
um I trust those of you that had the
opportunity to look at the information I
forwarded to you today and it might have
been a lot of it but it's it was all
particularly relevant
now as you all have read this
application relates to a proposed change
from approved wooden windows to Heritage
uppc in in a new build development
now I'd like to stress that Heritage upv
is a upbc rather is very similar almost
indistinguishable from Heritage type
wooden windows the advantage of those is
manifold and we're trying with this
development to be as eco-friendly as
possible we've got roof we've got roof
PV panels we've got EV Chargers it's
ready future-proof for changing to heat
pumps etc etc and one of the things
that's
um
stalling in or rather causing a problem
with that procedure is the wooden
windows because we're very close to the
seafront and believe me the weather in
that vicinity can be absolutely evil and
if you look around generally
the properties with wood and windows
which are in the in the minority they're
not in good condition because they need
constant maintenance constant painting
because of the situation and because of
the weather
now
um
the other reasons are for the for the um
for the change to ubbc is that the
thermal ratings are far better which
means there's going to be less
greenhouse emissions etc etc
um as as everybody's sort of is striving
for these days and considerably
increased sustainability because the the
Heritage ebvc and that mustn't be
confused with modern upvc which I think
is awful
um and it will last for a many many more
years than would will it will look smart
it will mean you won't get lots of
different colors being introduced it
will be uniform it will stay there and
it will look smart throughout
now my problem is
um I didn't just go ahead to fit upvc in
accordance with primitive development
rights which
the site does benefit from subject too
but I sought an agreement with the
planning department and I inquired if it
would be in order to fit these
underpermitted development now this is
the the Heritage upvc instead of the
approved wood and I was informed if I
wanted to fit the Heritage upvc I could
indeed do so under permitted development
but firstly I had to fit the permitted
wooden windows
and then I could remove them and then I
could put the PVC the upvc Heritage
Windows as we wanted to do
um I won't comment on that I think
probably most people have a view now the
to say the proposed Heritage style upv
windows and doors are identical to to
wooden there's very few Heritage Windows
left in the vicinity there's there's
modern upbc absolutely everywhere and
that has changed the character of the
conservation area could I just add Mr
chairman that the the application that
you dealt with for belgrave Road and uh
missed tomorrow so I I have to stop two
seconds no no I'm sorry you've had your
three minutes that had aluminum windows
sir sorry okay thank you we're talking
about this application now thank you
do this one
thank you sir
put the microphone on
um so the proposal is to vary the plan
condition on a previous application for
three dwellings to allow Windows to be
upvc when they'd previously been
approved as Timber so aerial image of
where the site is it's the the cleared
site in the middle here so you've got
the the Fort Road Hotel you can see the
the Turner there as well
so this is the the the plan of the the
development that was approved in under
the 2020 uh permission for for three
dwellings so this is part of a a wider
development which we'll look at and see
the states on site at the moment
um so these are the approved plans
um some of you may have been on planning
committees previously when this
originally came before I'm looking
around and thinking some of you might
have been
um so this is uh the design of the the
three buildings on the corner the sort
of the turn of where it has the Cobbs
Place elevation
um so you can see that the materials are
actually annotated on this so you've got
slate roof stop facing brickwork to the
upper floors uh render on the ground
floor and you've got very traditional
style and pattern of fenestration and
indeed the design of the of the whole
building
uh this is the rear elevation so it's
actually sort of three story at the back
of these buildings so these windows are
less visible uh in the conservation area
um they are partly visible from Alkali
row
um but obviously you've got a slightly
different design of of sort of the top
floor of the rear
so this is the site at the moment so you
can see these are the the the three
units that are on the corner here uh you
can see that the rest of the row being
constructed along the left-hand side and
you can see the the forehead hotel at
the top of the image on the left there
so just to quickly go around with some
Google street view images of just the
immediate vicinity of the site so this
is the sort of almost opposite corner um
where you've got you can see there's a
modern infill that was built a few years
ago there you've got you know sort of
again pan different pattern of of
development
um but obviously some dwellings that are
there that are more traditionally
designed and obviously historic in terms
of how long they've been there you've
then got this late 80s development
that's directly opposite the row that's
there that's obviously upvc Windows um
very sort of
Richard Rogers style that was obviously
in Vogue at that period of time and then
you've got the row that's further up
which is directly opposite uh the row
that we're not looking at today which
runs up towards the Fort Road Hotel so
you can see again the sort of style and
pattern of both fenestration but also
the the design more broadly in that row
so as
um the applicants mentioned the proposal
would look to put in
um Heritage style upvc windows so the
proposal would aim to match the opening
style of those windows so as we were
looking at if I go to this one you can
see you've got three casement windows if
we're looking at the front elevation
three casement windows at the top floor
and then you've got sliding sash windows
at first and ground floor so the
proposal would have the same form of
openings but obviously would be with a
upvc product made to appear you know
similar in appearance to Timber Windows
obviously the information that we've
been provided with includes this this
detail in terms of the specification
which allows for inclusion of things
like
um you know the horns internal and
external bars and and there are
obviously a variety of products on the
market for this I was raise concerns
about the upvc in conservation areas
obviously
there is a it does very much depend on
the the form of the development at the
moment um if you've got obviously Timber
windows at the moment and the proposal
is to put you PVC and it depends very
much on the style of Timber windows that
you've got how old they are and there is
obviously a hierarchy that's looked at
in historic England terms of when we're
you would allow potentially
non-traditional materials in buildings
this is a new build development it
obviously was proposed with Timber
Windows double glazed Timber Windows as
well as the other traditional materials
of of slate brick render that you've got
there
um and so it you know it's our view that
to have a traditional material to match
the traditional design and the rest of
the materials is quite important
especially in a new development in a
conservation area which is quite a
prominent location within the Margate
Old Town
um and given the proximity that we've
seen from the the photographs we do
think that you know being on the
footpath or in that area that whilst
imitation windows are getting better
there's no doubt as things go on that it
would still be perceivable in terms of
the grain that you get from the wood
even if the style of Windows is getting
better in terms of the frame widths are
now coming down for you PVC Heritage
products
um
in addition officers consider this
specifically engages with paragraph 135
of the mppf and specifically that's the
local planning Authority should seek to
ensure that the quality of approved
development is not materially diminished
between permission and completion as a
result of changes being made to the
permitted scheme the example
specifically cited in the mppf is
through changes to approved details such
as the materials used and we do think
that paragraph is is directly applicable
to this application and therefore the
recommendation is to refuse thank you
thank you very much Ian
um I recommend the officers
recommendation is adopted because the
vice chair please second oh second
nature thank you members councilor
Auburn yes thank you chair
um I think the first thing that comes to
my mind
was uh
why accept the approval for having
wooden windows when you've got your
application
and then decide to change it why not put
those
show that though the windows that they
want now in the application
um that was just one thought
um
like you could say that they accepted
the wooden windows so that they will get
consent and uh and then come in as they
have done for uh a change
um
and
I accept what the applicant has said in
relation to you could put wooden windows
in and then take them out and put put
your once in afterwards but um I think
we're dealing with a bigger issue than
that
um
I've
I have said in the past that I think
obviously even we've listed buildings
not just in a conservation area that
you know we've got to look for modern
stuff I mean and the Africans quite
quite right about the cold the wind that
comes off to Sea where it's located
etc etc but um I think we've just got to
look at the specifics uh in relation to
the original application was with wooden
windows
and um
so I just like to hear what other
members have got to say thank you chair
thank you Council Auburn councilor wing
uh I mean I think it's about consistency
because right in the heart of the
conservation area in Ramsgate in fact
right in the right right on the edges of
Spencer Square where you've got listed
Georgian properties a upvc window has
been allowed on the front of a property
under permitted development right so I
think we've got to try and get some
control and I think this is the right
way to do it
I think we're now in a situation where
the cost of living is so bad that we
have to take into account trying to make
properties as as efficient as possible I
lived in a grade two listed building and
I can tell you when the wind blows in
the wrong direction you can put on as
much heating as you like and those were
you know refurbished windows that where
you try to reduce the amount it's it's
just not a pleasant place to live in and
we've got to start thinking that that we
take some control of this and it's good
to hear that the materials are changing
and they're looking more and more
realistic or more and more realistic as
as as wooden sash do
I I cannot see the juxtap position
between that that upvc window that was
allowed on Spencer Street that is
totally out of keeping and this which I
think would be a whole building with
similar uh upvc's historic historical
sash wind windows that I don't think
many people would even notice as they
walked past
thank you councilor in councilor Hart
thank you chair
um I know this road very well actually
believe it or not I'm supposed to go up
there quite a lot
um now I understand
uh Ian's concerns about the fact you
can't see the fact that they're wooden
because you can't see the grain of the
wood however if you put seven coats of
paint on it you still won't see the
grain of the wood so and you would
probably need probably eight just to
keep them from rotting I do agree with
councilor Wing I do I I think in an area
like this
um maybe the applicant was wrong he
should have actually put in plastic
windows when he did it when he put the
application in but I do think a Heritage
window is the right way to go it keeps
it warm it keeps it dry and we are
trying to make those better for people
not worse and I think if we're going to
put in a a wooden Frame Window all we're
doing is just harking back
to the olden days where Windows just you
had to have secondary glazing to stop
them getting cold and I think you know
we are trying to make a better place for
people to live and I think if we go for
a Heritage window not a cheap old
plastic window but a decent quality
Heritage window
um then maybe that will make the
people's lives who live there better
right to be honest with you I kind of
agreed to refuse this application thank
you thank you councilman
yeah thank you Jeff uh actually
councilor Hart said most of what I
wanted to say about the Heritage windows
and the fact that you can't actually
tell the difference between that and
wood when they're up there
um looking at the building across the
road having upvc slightly cheaper
looking windows in there
um that was allowed again we should be
consistent that if in an area uh
buildings new builds are allowed to have
upvc or a former upvc then it should be
allowed for all of them therefore I will
be agreeing
um with councilor Hart there and saying
no I can't agree with the uh refusal
thank you
thank you uh councilor printed thank you
um again really picking up from
councilor wing and councilor Hart uh one
of the things that would concern me with
wooden windows is the long-term
maintenance and uh you know I'm battling
with some wooden windows at the moment
um and it doesn't once they start to go
and look Tatty then they look absolutely
awful and I do think that we should be
looking at longer term maintenance as
well as the immediate
warmth and everything else and so I'm
inclined to again go against the
officer's recommendation thank you
councilman you wish to come back yes
please share I think members need to
um
look at what's at what they're saying in
relation to uh existing houses within
the conservation area you can change the
windows without consent you can put new
PVC in without consent unless it's
listed so if you're looking at an old
building and I'm just referring to what
councilor Wing said it's an existing
building and they put and it's not
listed within a conservation area you
can put upvc Windows in this is a new
build
and I think that's that's the difference
I'm not arguing for the sake that
obviously as I said earlier that we need
to uh look further in relation to how we
address listed buildings and properties
in conservation areas but I just find it
odd that you accept a planning
application with wooden windows and then
coming later so obviously you must have
thought about it before
um but I certainly would
um so I that I just wanted to make that
clarification chair thank you thank you
councilor Auburn
um if I may uh I believe it's councilor
rastan is putting his hand up I'm afraid
counciloratic and you can't speak
I've got no
I know I've got no and I don't think the
officers have
either
yeah um
I can't allow you to speak now because
debates has started I'm sorry
any other members wish to speak
okay thank you
um
the recommendation is for refusal it's
officers of recommendation those in
favor of that refusal please show
those against
right
that has fallen I turn to Mr Livingston
once again
thank you so in terms of members have
obviously expressed that they consider
that for this new development upvc
Heritage style is is acceptable
um in terms of the report uh what it
outlines is that this is a variational
condition but what it actually entails
is granting a brand new planning
application planning permission for this
development and as you'll see from
looking at the the section which talks
about the uh the Sam's contribution the
Sam's contribution on this development
for the three houses has yet to be paid
and now what that means is that we need
to ensure that if members are deferring
delegating for approval or just looking
to approve it that it has to either have
a new legal agreement linked to this
planning permission to secure the Sams
or indeed the previous obligation on the
2020 application is discharged via
payment before we issue the decision for
us to be in accordance with the habitat
regs now in addition to that obviously
I've shown members the extent of the
information that we've got about the
precise nature of the windows obviously
it would be our recommendation but
members don't necessarily need to take
this on would be for us to get the
precise details of the actual drawing of
the windows
um for that to be put in to ensure they
match the design of the development
that's been approved but I leave it to
members to determine which motion they
want to put forward
thank you Ian
um write Council heart
hey my understanding by that was that
I'm correctly if I'm wrong in is that
for us to agree or for you to now agree
for the Heritage Windows to go in
get the developer to pay the Sams first
and then agree the windows with as long
as they are matching what you think they
should match is that correct yeah
hey yes so it's there is a bit of an
either or here because this is this is
one of the situations where the Sam is
discharged on the old application then
we can issue the decision on the base of
their the development but then
alternatively it could be a new legal
agreement or obligation on the basis of
this new one
um in terms of the details of the
windows
um the option would be that it's
deferred to officers to get that
information before Grant or
alternatively this is within the gift
because this is a change to the the
application members could impose a
condition to require those details prior
to insulation now sorry installation
um the the reality is though I think as
you've seen from the photo there are
openings the windows are going to go in
so it kind of makes sense to probably
agree it before issuing a decision
because that's probably as you know as
quicker basically so if I was to read
out what it might entail as a motion it
would be
to defer and Delegate for approval
subject to either a legal agreement
securing Sam's contribution or discharge
of the obligation via payment under F
oblique th oblique 200857
with the with the submission of precise
details of the windows to be installed
to be submitted
he said I understood my members
counselor Council
okay can I have a second I'll second
that chairman
thank you it's councilor Saunders Dave
Saunders the members agree
we need to vote on that
so show of hands please if you would
those against
it
okay no I know I know it's getting late
councilor Keane I mean councilor
Auburn's always lost his football
we have on Epstein that's councilor
Auburn
that is carried
thank you members
thank you okay uh let me move on
moving on to item four e which is Gore
in farm minutes Road in birchington uh
speaking in favor of this application is
Mr wooden Mr wooden
I'm sorry we've kept you a long time
tonight but uh I've only got to try back
to Cambridge so anyway
and the M25 shut the crossing tonight as
well
um they see the sympathy you get here
don't you really uh
you have so you have three minutes
um good evening ladies and gentlemen and
thank you for the opportunity to address
the committee on behalf of the applicant
my name is John Wootton I'm a director
of The Firm of saviles and I'm the agent
to the applicant
as the officers report States this
application relates to an allocated site
in the thanet local plan
furthermore thanet District Council does
not currently have a five-year housing
Supply and as such presumption in favor
of sustainable development applies
therefore the principle of housing
development of this site has already
been established
planning permission is sought for the
erection of four dwellings the
conversion and extension of a listed
barn and the conversion of a cartilage
listed Barn
the site has been designed to reinstate
the historic farmyard site layout
placing particular emphasis on the
listed Barn which will form a central
Focus point for the development
the development is low density with
large Open Spaces with Landscaping to
the South and Northwest of the site
this design will preserve and enhance
the Heritage value of the site whilst
mitigating any impact upon neighboring
properties
a list of building consent application
has already been approved for this
scheme and thanet's conservation officer
has noted that the scheme will ensure
that the buildings are protected from
falling into disrepair and that limited
alterations are required to facilitate
the conversions
the nppf states that the development
should only be refused on highways
grounds where the proposal would create
an unacceptable impact on highway safety
or where the impact on the road Network
could be severe
a specialist highways consultant has
completed a road safety audit for this
scheme and has concluded that the
proposal will not have any detrimental
effect upon either highway safety or on
the road Network
the highways Authority have raised no
objections and there are no objections
from any other statutory consultees
in conclusion we endorse the officer's
recommendation for approval for this
scheme as it complies with all the
relevant national and local plan
policies and that will help to protect
important designated Heritage assets
whilst delivering much needed housing
provision
We Trust members will be able to approve
the scheme thank you thank you Mr Button
speaking against the application oh yes
under 20.1 is counselor cup
thank you chair and thank you members
I've read through the report that
accompanies this planning application
and I would like to highlight some of
the issues that it fails to raise the
location of the proposal sits on the
very edge of the village overlooking the
fields the report suggests that the site
is the in the center of an urban
environment whereas a better description
would be a rural urban Fringe which is
defined as a landscape interface between
town or Village and Countryside
there's this this site has a lot of
significant historical aspects in Early
Times Gore end was a small Port there
have been a prehistoric Roman and
medieval remains found in the area
between and between 1272 and 1307 was a
non-corporate limb of the port of Dover
which unfortunately are downplayed in
the report
I worry that the Reliance on Suds to
deal with the surface water is unwise I
have driven Down Under the Railway
Bridge on many occasion to see how badly
flooded minus Road gets following even
very moderate rain many attempts have
been made over the years to address this
but unfortunately none have succeeded
the report inaccurately states that
there is a definite ownership separation
between the site and The Wider strategic
development St John's College Cambridge
is listed in the applicant details on
both applications that have been put
forward to this Council and it is common
knowledge that they own all the Farmland
in question
I'm also concerned what the impact may
be on the increase in traffic in this
area by having a third sequence of
traffic light minis road is the the main
route down into minutes Bay a beach that
is loved by many residents across
Burlington and thanet
but also by many tourists that come down
minutes road is already erode the
struggles to cope with cues of traffic
during peak season due to the current
two-way traffic light sequence
and there is not really an alternative
route the only other route that is close
by would take Vehicles over the very
narrow bridge on station approach which
would simply cause more problems and
issues
in conclusion the development would
effectively erase all trace of the early
history of gorend now minutes Bay whilst
failing to provide any material benefit
to the local community the detrimental
impact on residents the local views and
Landscape localized flooding under the
railroad bridge and access to minus Bay
far outweigh any benefits such a small
number of houses unaffordable to most
people in the area would have and I
asked the committee to refuse this
application thank you thank you Council
the cup I also have speaking on 20.1
against councilor fellows
I think thank you members I'm here as
Ward councilor to voice my opposition to
the proposed development of Gore and
farm the reasons for my objection are
multifold and include concerns about
highway safety and congestion impact on
the Heritage character and appearance of
the area destruction of local Wildlife
loss of privacy for the owners of the
adjacent grade 2 listed adjoining Gore n
Farmhouse first let me address the issue
of Highway Safety and congestion the
addition of a third traffic light
sequence in the area will not only
significantly increase traffic but
indeed cause even greater congestion
along minnis Road especially during the
peak summer period when it can already
take more than 15 minutes to get from
the bottom of birchington High Street
through to the traffic lights towards
minutes Bay the resident of Gore and
Farmhouse over the past two years has
observed that the current third traffic
light situated in the proposed
development is has only been activated
when a vehicle leaves the site during
these two years he has only seen this
light activated twice however
the proposed development would result in
a minimum of seven cars or likely to be
in excess of 14 cars not to mention
other vehicles coming and going
throughout the course of the day
proposal illustrates a trip generation
assessment which shows an additional
three cars during the morning peak hours
between 8 and 9 A.M however as I elated
earlier the number is significantly
higher given that the planning proposal
shows car parking spaces for 15 cars
which doesn't account for any visitor
spaces which we know there will be
during Peak rush hour is reasonable to
assume that most cars will come and go
potentially resulting in one car leaving
every four minutes during the hours of
eight and nine am and five to six pm
time frames this increased traffic
Global not only result in longer wait
times for local residents and emergency
services that use them in this road
route as the main access point to minis
Bay not only will this result in
increased air and noise pollution from
waiting cars but it will also make it
harder for emergency vehicles to
navigate throughout this area putting
resident safety at risk
Additionally the condition the
congestion will have another negative
impact on the quality of life for those
who live near this development along
both sides of minutes Road I must also
point out the number of near-misses and
accidents that have been witnessed under
the bridge involving vehicle cyclists
and pedestrians this too will be
increased especially when refuse or
large vehicles are trying to exit the
development as the proposed to access
and visibility layout it appears that a
13 meter refuse truck will need to mount
curbs to safely clear the exit
the point where the truck would Mount
the curb is directly on the proposed
pedestrian Crossing and the pedestrian
entrance to the development is also
noted that when exiting the development
by a vehicle you are completely blind to
oncoming traffic in both directions
next I would like to address the impacts
of this development would have on the
heritage heritage character appearance
local views and Landscape setting of the
area Gore M Farm is a rich
archaeological history dating back to at
least the 16th century and a unique
Farmland character that sets it apart
from other areas of thanet the proposed
development would completely Wipe Out
the history of Gore and farm and Destroy
The Farmstead character that makes it so
special
two of my residents have worked so hard
to protect the character of Gore and
Farmhouse by lovingly and sensitively
we're still in the beautiful grade 2
listed house to its former glory in
original proposed use
tdcs are out there every port oh can I
continue chair I am TDC throughout their
report refer to the importance placed on
safeguarding and the architectural and
historical importance of the listed
building and its setting yet you are
potentially approving a development
which would result in exactly the
opposite throughout agreeing to overtly
domesticate this existing Farmstead
would result in a significant loss of
historic character that cannot be undone
although it's not necessarily grounds
for refusal I think it's worth
highlighting that there has been several
offers and attempts with Saint John's
College to purchase this land and at all
above the market value in order to
protect repair and bring back the use of
this land and buildings for its original
intended use as a farm The Proposal
would reincorporate the gore n Farmhouse
and goreen farm as one complex
protecting enhancing the both the
architecture landscape and the story to
wind up counselor plenty more to say
cheers
okay in conclusion I oppose the proposal
in Farmers for several reasons firstly
the additional of the third traffic
light sequence secondly development
would destroy the Heritage character of
unique unique Farm character and area
caused it to be over domestically in
nature and as a result to lose the rich
archaeological history dating back to at
least the 16th century so I urge members
of the committed strongly consider the
impact of this proposed development
carefully and to make it to prioritizes
the well-being of local businesses and
the preservation of the unique character
in history of this area thank you hello
thank you
foreign
I'm sure you could
thank you I'm gonna ask the off planning
officer which is Annabelle on this
occasion please to give the report
yeah thank you chair
so this is the application site outlined
in red we have minis road across the top
here
goren Farmhouse is to the east here and
it's not within the application site
there are areas outlined in blue here
which are land within the applicant's
ownership but not within the application
site
so this is an aerial view of the site
minis Road here go ahead and farm agoren
Farmhouse here and the application site
is in this location here
[Music]
so the application is for residential
development for a total of seven
dwellings which includes conversions and
also new build development itself
so so the site is actually a mix of
previously developed and
non-privaciously developed land and
which has been seen from the previous
slide so this building here is the
freshing barn that's been being referred
to it's grade two listed
and this building here is a Cow Shed
that is courtesy listed
so and as has been mentioned it is part
of the wider strategic allocation for
the birchington site
but it is considered a self-contained
site in its own right and it's not
considered that it's Development coming
forward of this
the largest street education would
Prejudice that application coming
forward in in any way
so just looking at some photographs of
the site this is taken from minutes road
so you can see The Farmhouse there of
its access and the Cow Shed to the right
of that photo
this is looking at the existing access
into the site and you can see the
Railway Bridge and going across there
so this is into the site and we're
looking at the side of the threshing
Barn which as I've mentioned is grade 2
listed in its own right
um we're looking to the western boundary
of the site you can see the mass that
was adjoining the site it's not within
the application site but this area on
this part of the site is
as part of the photo is we're looking at
the office side and rear of the site so
the sort of overgrown or more overgrown
area is the application site you're
looking to the Farmland to the rear of
the site is knocked within it the
application site and that's looking to
the West the eastern boundary of the
site
this is looking towards Gore in
Farmhouse so that is out with the
application site
and there's the properties obviously on
minutes Road and minutes Road sits to
the front
there
and we're looking back where we started
so we've got the traffic lights on minis
Road there
The Farmhouse here
and the Cow Shed there
excuse me so as has been mentioned we
are looking at
um
sorry we are looking at seven dwellings
and I'll take you through the various
plots so
plot one is here
and we'll look at that so this is the
Cow Shed in the existing elevations of
that building
so this is how the northern elevation so
looking towards from minutes Road would
look so you have the existing Cow Shed
and this is actually a new bit building
that's adjoining it
this is a southern elevation so again
this is existing Cow Shed here
and then we have the Western elevation
of the Cow Shed
and indeed the Eastern elevation of the
same building you will note this is the
building that is closest in proximity
The Farmhouse that's been a referenced
the building is single story
and it actually set as we've seen from
the
site plan sets sits forward of the main
Farmhouse it would look out onto
um the sort of front garden area of The
Farmhouse rather than
impacting on any private space for The
Farmhouse as such
these are the floor plans of The
Farmhouse so you see the bedroom spaces
are mainly in this location here so
that's the new bit that's added to it
and this is existing
um living Sorry the existing Cow Shed
where the main living area for that
property would be and they're the two
openings there The Farmhouse sits
back here if you were took a look at it
on site and that's just the roof plan of
it
um you'll note there's a building here
that is actually a cycle and
been installed so we just have a quick
look at those elevations so we've got a
Cycle Stop a cycle store and Bin store
here a carport and that's the edge of
plot one
and that's what you would see if looking
for minis Road of that building
over the wall and just looking at the
floor plans the bin store here a cycle
store and a carport
so looking on to plot two and three
these are the ones that are within the
refreshing the converted threshing barn
with a small extension to make plot free
so this is an excellent sections of the
existing threshing Barn just to give you
an idea of its size and scale as it
stands now
um so this is a freshing part Barn this
is It's Western innovations that would
be looking out
towards
the tunnel although
the railway tunnel essentially
and this is the north North elevation of
the threshing Barn
and this is the Eastern elevation so
looking towards the Farmhouse and you
can see the single story extension that
we've looked at here
and this is the South elevation
as you can see the materials proposed
are traditional and the sort of thing
you would find on a farm yard and they
take you through
the existing materials on within the
vicinity
on the extension but also reusing and
fixing and the the freshing barn itself
to ensure that that is kept and
maintained
so this is ground floor of the unit so
this is unit two here and this is unit
free and that's a small single story
extension we looked at
and this is the first floor plan so unit
two here unit three and as has been
mentioned that's only a single story
extension to the freshing barn so it
keeps its main shape as being a long
traditional
bone shape
um so we're looking at plots four five
and six and they are new buildings and
they'll be in a Terrace in this area
here
so this is the northern elevation of the
barn so that would be facing onto
minutes row but they are obviously set
far far back into the site so you
wouldn't get an immediate view of them
from minutes Road
that's the self-elevation
so
and it um excuse me the flank elevation
so you're looking at plot six here which
is the most eastern
building in that Terrace and it's this
plot four which is the on the western
side of that Terrace again they are
looking to utilize traditional materials
in this instance cladding to try and get
tight into the the buildings already on
site and the historic sort of notion of
having a farmyard development
on the site so we have the ground floors
of the properties here
the first floors
of the site and the roof plan
so the last building to look at is plot
seven
um again a new build development and
it's quite an interesting
building
as you can see it's
um mainly single story of a two-story
element here
and that so it's that's it's north
elevation that's itself elevation
it's eastern elevation and it's Western
Innovation this is the ground floor
floor plan as you say it's an
interesting shape
and this is this only element of the
building that is actually two-story the
majority being single story
and it sits roof plan
um there's
landscape this is the landscape strategy
plan
um you will note there are areas of
landscaping proposed
both along where the access sits at the
moment because it's slightly being
realigned in this too
been
to not Bend as much and curve around it
will go straight on to the Minnesota
road so there'll be Landscaping here
with existing access it's there's also
additional Landscaping
into the rear of the site here and some
Landscaping here there will be some
trees that are lost in the development
but they are of low uh categories
and it is considered with the additional
planting and things that will be
provided on site together with
ecological enhancements in terms of bat
boxes and various software
habitats that could be created in these
landscape Wildflower Meadow sites excuse
me that the loss of those trees will be
mitigated
uh concerns have been raised about
highways and the impact of the
development on the highways and
particularly
the fact there will be enough a set of
traffic lights on the site
we're looking at this Photograph here
that's the Cow Shed here the farmyard
there of The Farmhouse there and you you
note the traffic light there with the
car waiting and so there is existing
traffic lights as I'm sure members know
either side of that bridge and tunnel
uh this is the existing access and as
has been mentioned it's actually already
controlled by traffic lights so there is
a third set already there and that was
used to control Farm vehicles coming out
in and out of the site
um in any case so
it's
going forward it will be a similar
Arrangement the access is moving and
becoming more straight on from where it
is now and not curving but it will also
still be served by a set of traffic
lights but it is
essentially replicating the existing set
of traffic lights that already exist so
it would not be a new set and it would
not be a
a new thing to have traffic lights there
in yes the farm yard hasn't been used
for a number of years clearly for Farm
vehicles coming in and out on a regular
basis but it's not to say that at any
time a farmyard couldn't you know an
agricultural use or different use
couldn't come there and the traffic
lights be operated
on a regular basis
there has been no objections from
highways subject to the traffic lights
and the additional conditions we've
heard about
um the conditions already set out on the
report and the additional condition
that's been recommended to do with the
details of the traffic lights that are
going to be put in being submitted and
agreed with highways
there will also be a pedestrian Crossing
and there are progesterone visibility
splays
mention has been made about whether the
access is suitable for refused vehicles
and tracking diagrams
have been provided so this is actually a
plan showing the access as it's been
realigned and proposed to be realigned
and the traffic lights would sit here so
they move from this sort of location in
this direction here
over to this location but highways raise
no objection to it subject to those
details being submitted and agreed with
them
and refuse vehicles have been tracked
and larger vehicles have also been
tracked and it has been found
that there is potentially a slight issue
with vehicles coming and turning right
from so we have a series of tracking
diagrams they may be rather difficult to
see
because they have a lot of detail on
them there might be a slight um overhang
when vehicle a refuge vehicle turning
right but it is very minor and there is
no reason why Refuge vehicle
would you know could be built into their
route to turn left and that has been
something that's been raised
and even if so it is or no weekly basis
or so that the Refuge Vehicles would be
entering the site
so
so going back to sum up really it isn't
an application for residential
development on an allocated housing site
it will in officers opinion
help to preserve and keep the curtain
the sorry the grade two listed Barn in
its own right as well as the curses
listed
Cal shed
it will provide accommodation and add
housing stock of various sizes to the
district's housing need and it will
provide Green Space and
biodiversity and net gain it there are
also no impact in terms of impact on
terms of residential amenity
um with safeguarding conditions drainage
is considered acceptable archeology
impacts
so it is considered that most things are
safeguarded by conditions and the
recommendation now has has been set out
by Mr Livingstone is for members to
approve the application
thank you thank you Andrea you've heard
the recommendation
I moved the office's recommendation is
adopted because the vice chair please
second
members
do I have any
Council heart
nature
um
I have
one concern which is the vehicle's
turning right but I think that could be
addressed by widening the road or the
access out so I don't think that's a
major issue and I think that could
easily be adopted and altered there's
enough room there
um and I did speak to the local highways
chat today
um who explained to me a little bit more
about the traffic light system and this
afternoon and he was very happy with it
I think it's a very imaginative use of
the site I think it's a good use of old
barns I think it's a a good
use and a nice place to put houses for
people to attain to
um to try and get to a place like that
and I think it's a good use of the space
and I I have no reason to refuse this at
all thank you thank you very much
Council right thank you chair
um I'm a little bit shocked that the
applicant has said that there is nothing
no objections from the local people the
parish council have
sent their comments in off the refusal
the residence Association are up in arms
about the development
the the officers have obviously never
been along with this road during the
summer when it is gridlocked
it's what it's literally one car one way
one car another
the and I don't think anybody the the
the cow sheds
is is a very special place
and if if if if the application goes
ahead
um I think that it should be the
exterior should be kept as is now to
keep the streets you know that is that
is very important the other thing is I'd
like to ask the officer have you located
the well
well
do you want to speak
[Music]
um bear with me councilor Wright um
are you aware of the well on the well on
the site
I haven't actually found it myself but I
am aware there is a well in the the
person right
sorry I didn't
the owner of the The Farmhouse has got
the map
which shows the well
I'll email when I get my part I will
email it to you
thank you but I think I don't think it
will have an impact
um I understand the land has been
surveyed and all those sort of historic
features would have been picked up so I
don't think it will hopefully Prejudice
the layout that we're looking to agree
tonight thank you
thank you councilor Garner
and get
thank you
um yeah I'll come to this
unlike a number of people here I'm not
I'm not overly familiar with this area
so I did do a little bit of
a little bit of research and looked up
some um pictures of of the site and of
the buildings and
both councilors fellows and
cupped have have updated us as a bit
about some of the history of the site
and I when I listened to the um
agent speaking I was interested to hear
he was saying about how this development
would enhance the listed building status
of the site
and protect them
important designated Heritage assets and
I sort of thought
it was a shame it's a shame that Saint
John's College the owners of the site
haven't thought about doing that over
the last few years because look at it
even just seeing from the picture shown
here looking at some other these
buildings have seemed to have been
allowed to fall into a state of
disrepair
almost
as if you know it would enhance getting
an application like this
um prepared
so I think it is a shame and and I I
have had a good read of some of the
surveys here and it's noted in the
reptile survey
that St John's College Cambridge have
allowed
Network rail to scrape the majority of
the site uh I think it's about 18 months
ago to enable
um
that to be used as a site compound for
works on the railway and I I saw that in
the in the reptile survey where it was
noted that this is a site where there
were an abundance of reptiles and other
biodiversity on the site that have been
previously decimated and are now
returning
um that I think if I look at this the
ecology survey was 18 months old
on the application and since then you
know to even noted in then that these
reptiles were coming back and I'm sure
that's much improved and one of the one
of the concerns I had in the
ecology survey it mentions a mitigation
site and I was just going to you know
moving of some of the reptiles off of
this site onto a mitigation site which
it seems to me is
that mitigation site will actually be
affected
but potentially affected because the the
other application for
1650 house units
I think that mitigation site is part of
that so these poor lizards are going to
be moved off of this site onto another
site which is then going to be decimated
potentially when there's when there's a
new site
um
one I mean there's a there's a number of
other issues I'll just mention a couple
um a tree survey
there's quite a lot of even our tree
officer mentioned and an amount of
ambiguity in the tree survey that was
provided by the applicant although they
did mention that some of the new trees
as you can see on that picture actually
the south of the site
um and I think you can bet that unless
they're well protected within a year or
two
um the new occupants of some of these
houses are going to be asking for them
to be filled because they're on the
south of the site they're going to cause
a lot of shading on them and we know
what's going to happen if we're not
we're not careful to protect them
um so there's another point I'm not very
happy with but I did want to just
clarify for Arthur one point of
clarification the site is as is
mentioned designated in the local plan I
think it's site sp16
for
up to 1600 dwellings on the site so this
this site here that we're looking at is
part of that wider SP 16 site isn't it
so
those up to 1600 dwellings can be
delivered on this whole site sb16
without this site this particular site
being impacted at all because the other
application
is for 1650 so
I just want to clarify what is because
it is part of that site doesn't mean we
have to approve it because it's
designated for housing the whole SB 16
is designated for housing isn't it so
this part of sb16 might not be
built on at all not needed at all to be
affected and who could still deliver
once requested it or what's mandated
almost
in the local plan so maybe it's somebody
you could just clarify that for me thank
you bank accounts Garner um before I
bring in cancer over it
I'm gonna bring back in and then
Annabelle just to come back on a couple
of points I'm just going to deal with
the plan bit and then Annabelle can
clarify with us the habitat mitigation
um
as you say it's part of the overall
allocation
um and at the point that the report and
look at that principle is that this
development wouldn't Prejudice the
ability of the the overall allocation to
bring forward that number of of houses
in terms of obviously what's been
proposed it's obviously proposed to
develop this site and it is part of the
allocation so the principle of
development
is acceptable for residential
development on this site the
hypothetical of this site doesn't get
delivered and the rest of the dwellings
are built on the rest of the allocation
isn't what's being proposed and we can't
compare it to that we have to look at
the merits of the case in front and in
this instance it's the principle of
development is that the site is
allocated for housing and therefore it's
about the merits and indeed of the other
considerations that can be looked at
um just bring Annabelle in about the
mitigation
yes so just going back to this landscape
plan there's an area here and areas to
the rear of the site here that are
actually the mitigation for the reptiles
Etc so it would be on-site mitigation so
it's not moving them
um away from the side
it may be just containing them in
certain areas of the site
but yes it has been noticed from the
ecological reports that they are coming
back in case this year as our ecology
advisor our
uh are in agreement with those
mitigation areas so
thank you thank you Annabelle
sorry can I just quickly come back just
while it's while it's being discussed
just come back on what Mr Livingstone
said so as I could just fully so as we
can all just fully understand it so
in fact you're in a way you're you're
saying that the applicant St John's
College Cambridge actually
[Music]
they've been quite
clever or quite quite well planned in
how they've done this in that by
bringing this forward first they've made
it difficult for us to refuse it whereas
if they'd have done it all in one go
they could have delivered what we've
asked them to or what they've got
mandated in the local plan without
having to do all this to the Heritage
assets that they had talked about being
so concerned about protecting
I'm I must I don't know the the
background behind the overall allocation
so I think the key bit here may be that
we sometimes have strategic allocations
not necessarily of birchington scale but
you can obviously have multiple sites
that are allocated under one policy but
actually they've got multiple different
owners obviously the application that's
been submitted for the the much larger
housing site has obviously been put
forward on the basis of
um for time we're going to land who
obviously have a a discrete option on
that land to develop it for housing and
obviously that will at some point come
before members uh of the committee to
determine again I think it does come
back to
we have to consider what's in front of
us that's not committed development
hasn't got planning permission and
therefore it needs to be put in the
context of the policy framework and in
this instance obviously it's it is an
allocated housing site and the main
issue with the the overall policy is
just to make sure that we're not
prejudicing it the example without going
on too long so I appreciate it's late
the example I'd give you is one in
briary close that members may have been
familiar with which is part of the
Westgate allocation a number of years
ago and it came forward for development
when the site was being the overall
allocation was being proposed and it was
refused by the Council on the basis that
it would Prejudice the overall
Development coming forward because it
was a piecemeal development well that
was overturned by an inspector who
considered that it was self-contained it
didn't harm the ability of The Wider
site to come forward and this is exactly
the same it's a case in point so we
don't have any significant concerns
about the impact on the overall
strategic allocation thanks
foreign
yeah thank you chair I mean it seems to
me there's an awful lot of work going on
here just to develop seven properties
um there are 35 conditions in the
planning report I think if I understood
correctly there's going to be another
one which we which was mentioned at the
start of the meeting about traffic
um I I understand that local people may
not want to see this site developed and
um I listened to what was said in that
respect I think for me the issue would
be about the impacts on many spying on
the traffic lights as it happens
um I was down there earlier this week
because I had to go to a wake at one of
the venues down at the seafront and I'm
always amazed by that Junction it's um
clearly not very satisfactory very
modern or much that anyone could do
about it but I look at the fact there
are only seven properties there
and I look at the fact that
um KCC are able to reach an agreement
about how that Junction would operate
and I'm not really persuaded by the idea
that having seven properties there is
going to make it significantly worse and
I think you know I absolutely accept
that um there are traffic cues there in
the summer and that it's very far from
being an ideal situation but I don't
think that the addition of the traffic
from those properties is going to make a
significant difference and certainly not
significant enough to reject this
application so um I think that in terms
of what's actually proposed that it's um
quite a nice development and I think it
makes good use of the Heritage assets
and as much as we might like to think
that that the owners would have
maintained them and looked after them in
a proper State without the incentive
that they've got in terms of making
money out of a development I think
that's probably not the real world so I
should be voting in favor of it thank
you uh thank you Council Robin
yes thank you chair
um
I like it uh just pure and simple
uh the renovation of the two listed
structures is to be welcomed whether or
not they've been left to go into uh
uh rot a little bit a bit like than it
district council with its listed
buildings we don't do anything with them
either most of them
um so um you know I think this is a
decent development the uh design of the
buildings and the new buildings fits in
I think it's lovely itself contained in
in in in that area it is part of the
policy that we've got as a housing part
of a housing policy and uh I'll be
supporting the offers exactly a
recommendation thank you thank you
Council Peter
thank you chair yeah I mean it can't be
denied it's not an unattractive
not if not on an attractive site
um uh but on the the land is allocated
for housing
um appealing as the idea of seven new
properties is I very much doubt these
will be affordable
and it is to me seems a great pity that
the a great deal of the
Heritage of the area will be lost apart
from the obvious potential impact on
highways so
yeah I'm a bit torn thank you thank you
I have three more speakers
um and then I will draw a line under
this debate Council heart
thank you
um I spoke earlier to be fair I don't
think seven houses are going to make
much difference the traffic at minutes
but I go through there an awful lot and
in the summer I just go the back way
anyway so I mean most locals will do
that anyway they won't go through the
bridge that's just for the tourists
um so I don't think it's a major issue
don't look at me like that Linda you
know damn well they go the back way
um well well
um but so realistically those traffic
lights won't be most differs the traffic
at all in and out of the Village
um so I think it's a good idea and I
believe by talking to Mr valik today
that the other properties that Council
Garner was talking about will have an
entrance further up the road
um nearer the doctor's surgery rather
than this end so and that'll probably be
by around about anyway so the traffic
flow is going to increase if that gets
approved anyway and seven houses is
going to make much difference really to
many space thank you thank you
um just just to come back on on that in
terms of the other application I think
the reality is the extent of Highway
mitigation for the Strategic site is is
is extensive and indeed encompasses
parts of minis Road as well as other
Junctions obviously includes a brand new
infrastructure as well uh you know that
that is something that's going to need
to be considered uh for that application
and given if this is approved this will
be committed development that this would
then have to be taken into account in
the birchington application you know one
follows the other
um so yeah there are there are potential
for other mitigation schemes but
obviously that's not as part of this
this proposal thank you Council grendon
thank you
um I've been quite conflicted at the
start of this debate and so I've been
listening to what everyone else has to
say and I'm still conflicted
um I like others I'm not sure that seven
houses will make a huge difference on
the traffic and there's a lot I like
about it but what I haven't heard is
really anything that addresses
um what the presentation was at the
beginning from councilors cup and
fellows about the wider historic issues
that will be impacted on this area I've
heard a lot about preserving buildings
but not necessarily The Wider area
um and I I guess one question I have is
can I just double check
um
do we have any choice will this be built
on because it's going to get built on
um whether it's this one or another one
um
or is it you know is it designated I
think it's the right word I think I've
heard it is but I just I just want to
double check that it's on the local plan
uh I'll bring back in yeah so it's
doesn't it obviously
you know depending on the decision it
you know depends on
any successful appeal obviously
depending on what's refused I think just
to come back on the main point um in
terms of archeology obviously they have
produced a desk based evaluation that
has been looked at by the county
archaeologist County archaeologist has
agreed with the assessment that's been
done and has recommended specific
conditions that have been required which
would need to be carried out
um you know prior to the development
commencing there's a grampian condition
to ensure that both field evaluation
works are undertaken and any fines are
recorded there's also building recording
condition as well so you've got both
you've got the built Heritage and then
you've got also got the the other
Heritage as well in terms of all about
that so
um whilst obviously the significance has
been outlined in terms of the site
obviously we rely on the professional
opinion of the county archaeologists to
give us the view on whether or not what
they what the applicant has proposed is
sufficient to Accord with policy he1 and
it is considered
that it would
thank you
thank you thank you Ian um councilor
wing and then I say I'm drawing a line
I'm just distracted don't worry about a
diabetic alarm
I'll need clarification on one point
which I think two of my colleagues have
uh tried to get to the bottom of and it
confused me in a previous planning
application sometime back so I'm trying
to educate myself going forward
if a site is allocated for a hundred
houses and we get to a hundred houses
and then somebody wants to build 10 more
do we have different powers that's the
first that's the first thing I'd like to
clear up in my head
so
um the allocation of housing sites
usually includes a notional number so
most of our allocations have a broad
amount of of houses that's all in a big
table of back of the plan the main
allocations though so in this instance
the five strategic allocations
um all have a up to number which is
obviously based around housing need
distribution of housing infrastructure
all that sort of stuff if a number of
applications come forward that exceed
that amount the question would be
whether or not that's contrary to the
policy or whether or not it could be
considered now in the in the in
likelihood any strategic planning
application on those big sites is coming
before members so if we are outlining to
members that it's contrary to this
policy because of this we'd obviously
have to be saying why we think it's
acceptable so uh again this is showing
I've been here too long but the case of
Westwood cross we had an application
years ago where uh all we had the big
allocation and it was approved as 1100 I
think it was and then we had a
subsequent application on the end but
within the allocation for more houses
for another 40 I think it was or
something like that
um and and there were concerns raised
about the fact that we were adding them
on when they weren't needed now that was
a very different policy framework at
that point and obviously it's much more
permissive now subject to considerations
so I think you know this is factored
into the other allocation you know it
does kind of Whittle down the number to
some extent that can be afforded to the
overall site but it's all about what's
mitigated with the bigger site when it
comes forward
okay so my my I won't comment on what
other people have said but it's been
really useful uh I want to concentrate
on uh water
uh and it's very interesting it's always
interesting when you have Ward
councilors or counselors that know the
area that drop into some information and
I think flooding was mentioned
so uh do we have any report from
Southern water at all
we've got a comment in the report
um flooding that's as interested are we
talking foul drainage or surface water
because what's been discussed it was
mentioned here under the bridge so so my
concern is that we we there will be
increased so there will be two two ways
flooding could be impacted here first of
all we've got an increased number of
Residential Properties which we'll use
and create additional Wastewater which
will enter our system
then I well I don't think many of us
think about is is we now have a
presently a piece of porous land which
water goes through and the biggest
problem with flooding is surface water
we're now put in non-porous structures
uh footpaths and roadways into this area
so in a sense we're going to we're going
to as a byproduct increase the amount of
water that is surface water and decrease
the amount which which Flows In
naturally through throughout our chalk
substrata and what it you know it goes
back to it goes back to us needing to
understand we have a critical problem
with our with our water and flooding and
discharges into the sea and I would like
to know I would like to see more
information from Southern water they're
not our statutory uh bodies to consult
with but in the two Southern water
meetings I've been to they said if they
were asked they would produce the
information so I'm linking the two
things together I I would like to
understand better the flooding and the
reason for the flooding and I'd like to
I'd like Southern water to model the
situation that these houses will create
and possibly the hundreds of other
houses that are created also the loss of
Farmland is never going to sit well with
me I also have concerns about the loss
of trees and habitats because in
developments in Ramsgate further down on
the West Cliff we've seen
we've approved the application and we've
said that all these trees around here
are going to be protected and then
suddenly people move into the properties
like Council Lagana says and we suddenly
see trees being failed left right and
Center so I think we need to start and I
don't know whether we can insisting that
trees are protected within development
so that it's not easy for people who
come onto site to start taking them down
so they're my concerns the potential
flooding which I think we need greater
information about particulars it's been
mentioned by people who know the area
more and also the protection of some of
that habitat which you know they say
they're going to put a wildlife
certain things in but how how could how
can we ensure that the trees that remain
are protected and the ones that are
replace the ones that are cut down are
protected for future Generations thank
you thank you councilor Wing once again
Ian
um so in terms of drainage can ignition
three is a grampian condition which is
to deal with foul water and surface
water so specifically would look at the
surface water Arrangements that are
being proposed on the site again hearing
what councilors say and it's it is
common knowledge about the underneath
the Railway Bridge in terms of
self-sword flooding obviously what the
applicant will need to do in submitting
those information to us is demonstrate
that there's no increase in runoff off
this site basically in certain storm
events so that is what that condition is
trying to secure and ensure doesn't
happen so this development couldn't
contribute to surface water problems
that are pre-existing in terms of foul
water Southern water have commented with
regards to the main present so they've
given a comment on the application they
haven't given a survey of the
infrastructure in the area this is where
planning crosses over with water
infrastructure act which obviously
requires Southern water to offer a
connection to anyone wanting to build a
house but it allows Southern water to
charge them the privilege of doing so so
when looking at the capacity of the
network in the local area and therefore
providing a tariff-based system where
they pay to increase the capacity when
they're connecting to the drainage
Network so that's mandated through the
water infrastructure act obviously what
we need to ensure is that we've they've
got adequate arrangements for foul water
that's also covered through building
rigs as well but obviously in terms of
that point about capacity which I know
is a particular issue that is covered
for by the water infrastructure act
obviously I'm not going to get into
Southern Waters effectiveness of that
that's not a planning consideration
unfortunately the
um but back to the surface water we do
think the cons condition is sufficient
especially given that he's a gramping
condition and that means that obviously
they they cannot do any development
until they've cleared that condition so
we think that's sufficient to deal with
surface water on the site thank you
[Music]
right onto this week again but I did say
I was going to draw a line
um writer members it's down to
yourselves adaptation is for approval
for those please show if you are in
favor
please show of hands
foreign
s
right let's have a did you have a count
up yeah four three box six against two
obsessions
right that has fallen members
which right
I apologies I'm slightly surprised about
that um okay so
um there is so if the the motion has
fallen there's no
I think any member that wants to propose
a motion I I think
I think I'm going to hark back to the
olden days and suggest a very brief
adjournment for them to approach the
bench to have a discussion because
from hearing the debate
um I haven't I haven't heard any reasons
for refusal
so
if we I can turn the microne off and
sure
I'm going to have five minutes
adjournment
um and if uh I think we all feel the
same there
um
and any member who wishes to come up
with a proposal
I would be grateful
uh thank you members
thank you members
down sacoma cook
be quiet
you spoke
I'm going to hand over to Ian for a
moment we have had some
point to put forward to us
which Ian will touch on and then we will
put the proposal to you thank you
thank you chair
um so following discussions with members
and hearing the particular points that
have been uh raised
um I think the officer recommendation at
this point given that the motion to
approve has fallen would be to recommend
for a site visit to occur for the site
to be looked at with further
clarifications from officers to provide
in a subsequent planning meeting with
regards to archeology drainage trees and
impact on biodiversity
we need a proposal right that if members
understand that need a proposal for a
site visit
like counselor Garner put his hand up
first I'll propose that thank you
councilor crindon has seconded
um the members agree
those who in favor of a site visit
please show the hands
foreign
those who are against
I'm going to go for a site visit
we haven't had one for a long long time
okay
okay members uh that's quite a long
evening tonight but um on Trudeau a lot
as always thank you very much to
officers and members and especially
those who've been subs tonight thank you
for coming along